hey everybody another day another white
house coronavirus press briefing I'm
considering changing how I cover these a
little bit and I'm gonna have a poll for
you guys in a moment about that once a
few more people connect to the stream
it's April 1st day 1 of 30 of 30 April
days of staying home we don't know
whether this is the beginning the middle
the end we just don't know yet and we're
all in this together we are all
relegated to having to bake I will be
baking later today and maybe later
people can give me advice on a I have
two overripe bananas so that's we I
think we already know the direction
things are going but you know there's a
lot of options I've got slivered almonds
I've got raisins I have cocoa powder so
there's a lot that could be done and I
will ask you for your advice a little
bit later let's get to the latest
numbers as we wait for this press
briefing scheduled for the top of the
hour and you know it might start at 5:05
it might start at 5:20 p.m. Eastern Time
we just we just don't know at this point
in time the official numbers let me
refresh the official numbers right now
nine hundred and twenty seven thousand
cases we will likely reach 1 million
official cases worldwide either later
today or tomorrow the death toll is very
rapidly approaching 50 thousand 50
thousand five zero we have the United
States we really are number one every
day more new cases in the u.s. already
22,000 new cases today we could
potentially it's possible we could reach
30,000 new cases today another brutal
day with 660 people dead let's look a
little more in detail at the numbers in
the United States let me refresh we just
we just picked up a thousand cases I
want to make sure you have the latest
numbers two hundred and eleven thousand
official cases in the United States
approaching five thousand deaths of
course right now let's just do let's
let's pull out the calculator just
because we have the time so right now
New York as well as New Jersey represent
that's gonna be about half
50% of the cases right now are in two
states New York or New Jersey but it's
really important to understand that New
York is just early New York is expected
to peak sooner because they got their
first cases earlier and so you've got a
place like Florida which already has
7,000 cases Ron DeSantis only today said
it's time for a 30 day stay at home it
doesn't start until Friday at midnight
so expect that places like Florida are
just going to explode because remember
cases are essentially you know seven to
fourteen days delayed if you don't go in
until about five days into your symptoms
and get a test the tests can take up to
eight days when a case shows up
officially that could be a case that
started two weeks ago so the Florida
numbers are absolutely going to be
exploding meanwhile Italy the death
numbers in Italy are still tragic but
the case numbers appear to have turned
the corner they appear to have turned
the corner and what's really important
to understand about these numbers again
is that when we say that we've peaked
that's not a one-day event the peak
often lasts 10 12 or 14 days and as you
can see it's now been 12 thirds we're on
like day 13 sort of of Italy's peak or
maybe we could say we are a couple days
now into the descent that gets us to the
latest estimates this is the best model
we currently have this is the IH m e
model increasingly dr. Burks and dr.
Fuji are looking at this model this is
dr. Christopher Murray's model we're
trying to get him on the program every
day data from the previous day is added
to the model so for example yesterday
this model said that the peak would be
April 15 yesterday was not a good day
this has adjusted the model the MOT the
peak is now expected to be April 16th
now importantly when we say the peak
will be on the 16th with 2607 deaths in
the United States that is just a one
possible outcome and there's a range of
likely outcomes so when we say the peak
will be 2600 people die on the 16th
could be as few as 12 94 as many as 40
140 but very
importantly the deaths per day are
expected to be over 2,000 starting on
April 8th lasting all the way until
April 28th that's a 20 day peak like the
difference between twenty six hundred
and seven and twenty six hundred deaths
can we really say that the the sixteenth
is the peak no we're gonna have about a
20 day period that is going to be the
peak and it's gonna be very very ugly
the yesterday the projected death toll
for this first wave remember we're
expecting three waves this one fall and
then spring 2021 yesterday the death
toll was expected to be 83,000 overnight
because yesterday again was a bad day
that has gone up by 10,000 the estimated
death toll now for this wave one is 93
thousand seven 65 the other thing to
note is that this range has drastically
expanded whereas yesterday the range was
forty to a hundred and forty thousand it
has now expanded to be anywhere from
forty to a hundred and seventy seven
thousand that's the confidence interval
so these are not good numbers and we're
following it daily and meanwhile the
grift continues here is Kenneth Copeland
with a hype man talking about as long as
you send him ten percent of your income
right that's the hole that you got to
keep tithing this guy I guess can pray
away the coronavirus people fall for
this elderly folks gullible folks
Christian folks I don't know
[Music]
in the office the prophet of God right
[Applause]
right so Ruth
imagine seeing this and saying hey you
know what I'm gonna keep going to get
haircuts I'm gonna keep going you know
to to to the mall but I'm gonna send
this guy cash and I'll be fine now
instead of God making coronavirus and
then the vaccine why not just skip the
entire thing and this guy right here
maybe the worst hype man that anyone has
ever had right so as you can tell this
this is very similar to what you hear
you know the the that guy on the subway
yelling right it's just this guy's
wearing a suit he has better makeup and
lighting that's really the difference
now admittedly this guy probably knows
this stuff is BS whereas the guy on the
subway actually needs you know to be in
a psych ward although if you're willing
to lie if he knows he's lying it almost
is more insidious in a way I'd rather
this guy merely be crazy
rather than be lying and knowing that he
is you know taking advantage of people
who send him money it's it's really ugly
it's very very ugly okay welcome if
you're watching on Twitter twitch
Facebook or YouTube all acceptable and
delightful platforms and I'm glad to be
welcoming all of you guys let me say a
couple of quick thank-yous before we
move on I do want to thank Lucas Norland
who is new member number one today at
join pakman.com my website also want to
say thanks to Chris Lamont
who is new member number two so let me
let me speak truth to power for a moment
if you will allow me to I know that you
know everybody is always supposed to
pretend everything is just great when
you do an independent show because you
want to keep the hype going and you know
it's all it there's a lot of theater of
the mind that goes on we just got our
final March numbers because it is now
April 389 members canceled their
memberships on our website in March
that's by far the most members we've
ever lost in a month and I get what's
going on
I mean people you know unemployment
could spike to 20 25 percent people are
laid off I get it
okay but I want to be transparent that
March was very ugly we you know losing
for us 389 members is a lot and people
are tightening the belt I don't blame
anybody people write to me they say
David I'm sorry but this is what's going
on you know so what I'm asking is I
don't want your last two dollars but if
you are in a position to be able to
support the work we do by getting a
membership on my website consider
yourself invited and with that coupon
code up there 20 20 now a monthly
membership is only two bucks a month a
yearly membership is only 20 which makes
it like a dollar eighty a month I
suggest paying yearly just get it out of
the way it gets us you know the the
revenue right away and then you you save
another 16 percent or so so consider
yourself invited three eighty nine is a
that's a big number we've never had that
many people cancel in a single month so
I invite you to sign up at join
pakman.com we have a modest goal of 25
members today okay let me answer some
super chat questions that are coming in
Donna Williams says what do you say to
Trump's cult members who defend by
saying he stopped flights from China
okay yeah I mean sure but he he failed
to do a whole bunch of other stuff so
all right I mean but by the time Trump
stopped China flights the Nexus was
actually Europe so you know take that
for what it is
Quincy vyg le no Miguel says pack we
love your hair it gives us elements of
hope thank you
Quinn's up let's see here aquatic llamas
has signed up at the beta level Emmet
says love the show David
he says every day I tell myself there is
fresh hope that these briefings will
improve then I realized Trump will
blather on and there is really no hope
at all okay so let me ask you this is
the question I have for you I want you
to go right now and vote at david
pakman.com slash vote because these
press briefings happen in three discreet
sections Trump shows up and lies and
self congratulate s' that's section 1
then doctors get to talk experts get to
talk that's section 2 and then Trump
takes questions from reporters that's
section 3 do you want me to skip section
1 where Trump propagandize --is okay
that is one option we can just will have
Trump up here we'll mute it I'll keep
talking to you guys and we can you know
what when we see that the doctors start
talking we go to that so if you go to
david pakman.com slash vote it'll take
you to this poll how should I handle
Trump coronavirus press conference if
you want me to carry the entire thing
let me know if you want me to skip the
propaganda intro from Trump and just do
doctors and questions let me know if you
want me to do only doctors and skip
questions let me know and then if you
want only questions you can also let me
know let's look at the oh my goodness
only four people have voted so far oh I
think people are saying that my website
maybe uh baby getting crushed again oh
no I think a bunch of people they're
trying to sign up and the website may be
getting crushed I just reset the website
guys I'm sorry let me paste the
strawpoll link I'll paste this I'll do
this in twitch and then I'll do it in
YouTube I'm unable to do it easily in
Twitter or Facebook right now and then
the website should be coming back up
very very soon I just rebooted it and I
apologize about that I think I I made
the mistake of suggesting people grab
memberships and suggesting people use
that redirect david pakman.com slash
vote and the web site is just getting
brutalized right now it can take two
minutes for it to reset so let's just
give it a second and then we should be
we should be back up and running
momentarily but I did just paste the
link to this straw poll in the chat and
let's see okay
Oh people overwhelmingly saying carry
the entire thing okay all right then I
will do that I I'm surprised by these
numbers from people from people writing
to me I thought more people would want
the propaganda piece skipped but about
80 percent say carry the entire thing
alright so we will do that but people
can continue voting let's see yeah it
seems pretty overwhelming okay well so
then we'll do it I I'm going to do what
what the audience wants is what the
audience gets that's always been the
case about 83 84 % say carry the entire
thing so we will do it we will do it
then and I will just do my best to to
fact-check and keep up the one thing
about skipping the propaganda part is
that the announcements on policy do seem
to happen during that time like when
Trump says we're extending for 30 days
or whatever if we skipped the Trump
piece we would miss that and that
wouldn't be that that would not be a
good thing at all okay let's see we are
I'm doing my best to get the David
Pakman show website to come back up it's
under very very heavy load right now a
lot of people trying to sign up and
we've upgraded our hosting twice already
and in fact if you'll allow me I'm just
gonna send a quick email to our
webmaster saying hey guys unfortunately
the website instantly crashed again
today when I went live and mentioned
signing up for membership what is our
next step here in troubleshooting
definitely want it to stay up throughout
thanks guys
very good that's that's my very polite
email to our team to see what we can do
we've I mean it's like we've upgraded
our hosting twice already and you know I
don't know how much how much more we can
do it's it's a it's a difficult
situation very very difficult situation
okay while we wait for that other super
chats coming in Quincy Fidel has grabbed
a YouTube membership
Charlie with $100 super chat says
everyone is like oh wow David's coverage
is so great and David is helping us get
through this you know what they're 100
percent right thank you thank you thank
you no thank you Charlie
I really appreciate really really
appreciate your support
Donna William says did you hear about
pence mistakenly sending a Plane full of
medical supplies to Japan no but what I
did tweet about is an article that
explains that a trumpet official called
Thailand and said to Thai officials hey
guys we need masks and PPE and the Thai
official said hold on a second you're
sending us a planeload of masks and PPE
right now like at the same time that one
Trump official was asking Thailand for
stuff a different Trump official had
sent Thailand the same stuff and it's
just it's a comedy of errors but it's
one of those comedies that is actually a
tragedy because people are dying as a
result of the as a result of the
incompetence it's absolutely stunning
and you know I don't know how much
longer this is going to go on but
apparently a while do we have any stream
that is that has the live room so we can
see what's going on let me see here
sometimes Washington Post has it
Washington Post coronavirus live not
finding it right now hmm okay well we'll
have to see about that it looks like the
david pakman show website is coming back
up for a few people so for example like
Bryan huff was able to sign up at join
pakman.com and petra ron holm was able
to sign up they are members number three
and four the website is struggling but
it is it is it seems that it is
intermittently coming back up for people
okay Waller is me says I am sad but not
surprised
Trump's gaslighting apparently continues
to be effective it is a super power of
his an idiot savant type ability it's
shocking to me too and you know I've
been heavily desensitized to it and
still it is stunning to
me the ease with which Donald Trump is
able to just Gaslight his followers into
believing any old dumb thing that he
says it's it's disturbing and stunning
Adam Waddington says Trump really needs
to stay at home and allow the smart
people to answer questions I sometimes
wonder if anyone coaches him before
these air I would rather not hear from
Trump at all like I would just want to
hear from doctors and experts 0 the
liger says I'm sending 10% to say this
ain't Satan's fault all right let me see
here Matt Chavez says what policies are
they passing while we are distracted
many and we've been talking about them
on the broadcast show and we've been
posting those clips too to our YouTube
channel and to our podcast by the way if
people may not know but we do a daily
hour-long podcast and it's an audio
podcast you can get it on iTunes
stitcher or website all of those places
and it's a great way to kind of get the
it's like an hour summary of the day's
news and I encourage people to to grab
that sign up for that love inspired says
where is my tambourine when I need it
Jacob Ratner says I'm a Zoomer who can't
remember 9/11 how would you compare that
situation to the one we face now you
know interestingly 9/11 and what we're
experiencing now have a similar feel the
difference is that 9/11 it was much
shorter and it was much more localized
the FAA ground stop of all planes
affected the whole country but most of
the country reopened very quickly so
this has a feeling like 9/11 in a way
but it is it is lasting much much longer
very clearly okay let me say thank you
to oh no nobody else I the website still
seems to be struggling to come back up
usually after like 10 minutes the the
the cloud hosting will adjust resources
we've we've got to do something about
this website hosting because it's
happening every time I stream that
people are trying to get memberships
and the website is just is just unable
to handle the traffic so maybe try avoid
hitting refresh too many times right now
cuz I think that's part of what may be
causing the problem at join pakman.com
and hopefully within a few minutes the
website will be back up let me say a few
twitch thank-yous I want to say thanks
to pensive for subscribing with prime
Quiggins prodigy has subscribed with
prime Goss good has subscribed with
prime Joe Buck Gump has cheered a
hundred bits and triple Z kuma has also
subscribed with prime thank you very
much
Thomas W says pack it up pack it in let
the neo-fascist propaganda begin shortly
shortly my friends Bjorn Eric Knutson
sends a smiley emoticon Thank You Anita
Morgan has grabbed a YouTube membership
opera man
a thousand says let the fool speak
Dominic Richardson says do you like the
Democratic Party you know I'm an
independent and I vote for candidates
not parties so I I don't have any
particular allegiance to the Democratic
Party itself Riley Potter has sent a
five-dollar super chat parrot Erin says
have you seen the Mad televangelist that
says somatic people Semitic people with
a specific religion are spreading the
disease due to God's punishment idiots
make me lose faith in humans couldn't
with clearly due to blocking I have not
seen someone blame the Jews if that's
the question on like I haven't seen a
televangelist blame the Jews I've seen
white nationalists blamed the Jews for
coronavirus but I've not yet seen seen
the televangelists do it Ori opposed
says keep going David Ferran balanced
keep it real cam says just watched a
youtuber who has cut her lupus
medication in half because doctors are
writing so many prescriptions I assume
you mean chloroquine yeah that's an
issue and I I mentioned that yesterday
on the program and that is a that is a
major major problem
let's see here okay standing by for what
was going to be a 5 p.m. press
conference they typically start late we
never know how late until they start but
we are standing by a slur says you
forgot to mention the fourth part of
these press conferences where pence
fawns and says the president the
president the president you're right
there really are four parts Trump lies
doctors speak questions and then pence
just brown-nosing Donald Trump Dan
stepka where did that go dan stop
Cosette stream it all keep interrupting
propaganda with facts yeah that seems to
be what people wanted I mentioned a poll
a few minutes ago 85 percent of the
audience says don't cut out the part
where Donald Trump tells lies so I won't
we will we will indeed leave that in
let's see here okay we have all right my
my my web development person says it's
time to upgrade posting right away I'm
going to say let's do it but I am
skeptical that alone will solve the
issue but let's try okay I have been
notified that the website is now back up
okay so I mentioned a few minutes ago
March was a brutal brutal month for us
389 people canceled memberships because
of what's going on and I get it
everyone's tightening the belt we're all
in this together we're all working
together to try to you know flatten the
curve and deal with this but March was a
was a tough month for us losing 389
members so my ask is if you've got a
couple bucks a month to spare consider
getting a membership at join pakman.com
that coupon code 2020 now will save you
66% so it's two bucks a month or 20 for
the year which is only $1 83 a month and
the the website is getting hammered but
it looks like it is now mostly back up
and people should be able to start
signing up which is very very much
appreciated
oliver mention
oh sorry Steve Gees has gotta look into
an auto scaling solution for your site
ramped up more resources when the load
increases you know that's what I thought
we had like I'm just a lowly host I
don't really I don't know that much
about that I thought that we had a cloud
hosting solution that's scaled
dynamically to the demands but maybe
it's it's clearly not working let me put
it that way
Oliver Minshall says David thank you for
talking about over-18 dependence on your
show I'm a college student and will get
no money in the bill even though I have
a tuition due in August yeah there's a
lot of people 18 to 24 who were
essentially independent but can be
claimed as dependents by their parents
and they will not get a stimulus check
question for you guys there is a ten
thousand dollar SBA kovat 19 it's kind
of a loan but it's a forgivable loan so
some people are calling it a grant and
it's something that business is affected
by Kovac can apply for tons of people
don't realize that as long as you use
the ten grand in ways to mitigate being
impacted by kovat you don't have to pay
it back so I'm wondering if you guys
think it would be useful for me to do a
video just walking people through how to
apply for this loan slash grant if
people think that that would be useful
and interesting
I could definitely put a video together
I talked about it with a couple friends
of mine who do uh who have their own
businesses and are being dramatically
affected that's maybe a sort of extra
video I could put together over the
weekend and it is quite a program I mean
it's it's it could be a UH it could be a
business saver for some for some
businesses so maybe that's something
I'll do over the weekend let's see here
Vasiliy Vanda says will unemployment
rate impact Trump's reelection too early
to know too early to know but it very
may well Brian Huff says hearing Trump
talk about closing travel to China is
like Al Bundy talking about scoring four
touchdowns in one game for pokai yes
it's essentially ancient history at this
point and it was too little too late
Dyanne Jones has grabbed the YouTube
membership dodging rain says I am
worried about Anthony foul G I share
your concern I'm worried about him both
in terms of the politics and because
he's 79 and he's you know as cases rise
I worry about him just getting the virus
which is a whole other issue altogether
let me say a couple of other thank-yous
Julius cup chefs key is new member
number five today at join pakman.com
thanks so much Julius very much
appreciate that and I understand the
website is still sort of struggling but
at least sporadically people are able to
get through and to grab memberships it
we my web person is working on it
literally as we speak and I will add in
asking her is there anything we can do
in the interim to get the website back
up lots of people are trying to get
memberships as we speak it's ugly folks
it's ugly out there the internet tubes
have been stretched to the limit Hugh
Jass says in high school policy debate
we debate Nietzsche Freud and
anti-blackness
the topic next year is criminal justice
reform thoughts how would you do well
without preparing I would do terribly
right I mean I think it's for those
debates it's all about preparation
Arthur should see says when Trump tells
a lie pointed out that's what I try to
do sometimes it's like a Gish gallop
there's just so many that it's hard to
keep up austin Agyeman says I'm looking
at the IRS website to see stimulus check
qualifications it seems most people will
get between three and eight hundred only
specific situations qualify for close to
1,200 what are your thoughts my
understanding was that qualifying adults
who are not dependents who were in under
seventy five thousand my understanding
was everybody got the twelve hundred if
that is otherwise then I would love to
know more about it
Riley Potter says I've been seeing
doctor
ouch should do a lot of interviews on
YouTube trying to reach an audience can
we trust him and do what he says or is
he part of the Trump propaganda team I
don't know I mean here's the thing
you've got to do at least what doctor
foul Chi says if you believe that he is
being unusually cautious for political
reasons do at least what he says and
that you know you're already if you do
that doing better than a lot of people
and you know I wouldn't be shocked if
soon we hear some kind of guidance on
where a mask all the time in public the
way they've been answering those
questions over the last couple of days
it would not be a huge surprise to me
Ryan nawicki says judge whoops hold on
where'd Ryan go Ryan no wiki says judge
Reggie Walton just recently forced the
Department of Justice to reveal
unredacted molar report for review to
confirm redacted parts as appropriate
what are your thoughts I have a few
articles about that bookmarked which
I've not yet read so I'll probably
comment tomorrow Chris Davidson says if
citizens united says corporations are
people then no corporation should get a
bailout over $1,200 if they make under
75 K and no money if more than 99 K yeah
don't hold your breath for that
Brian Somerville has grabbed a youtube
subscription bur most says I'm watching
from Europe and it's really concerning
what's happening over the pond stay
strong and safe guys really enjoying
your show though yeah the numbers are
truly starting to get scary here we now
are at two hundred and eleven thousand
official cases in the u.s. real number
is probably one to two million maybe we
are approaching five thousand deaths and
we'll be there likely later today or
tomorrow 50% of all official cases
remain in two states New York and New
Jersey Michigan having a big growing
problem California on a per capita basis
remember California has about 30 million
people that is a big big that that is
it's it's an accomplishment what
California has been able to achieve
I mean look here in Massachusetts we
have a much smaller population and we
have almost the same number of
official cases official cases okay let's
see here did things just freeze because
it looks like the looks like the YouTube
chat briefly froze and a couple people
told me that I froze Wow so a lot of
things just going wrong at once good on
people all right it seems like we're
okay unfrozen already some people saying
California's numbers are low because
they are they're not testing currently
that that maybe I don't know that much
about them okay Kat titanium mellon
Parker says has anyone asked Trump his
take on a rent freeze I've not heard
that question during the press
conferences so far burrows has grabbed a
soy boy level membership as has Chris
Flores marika says support for the
nationalistic parties in Finland and
Sweden has gone down a bit during the
corona crisis a bit of good news at
least that is good news
Kowalski from Nebraska is now a beta
member Lance Cooper has upgraded to
alpha friendly-fire says people want to
listen to Trump because we all love his
nonsense that's why he'll probably
reelected we love and hate his reality
show what are your thoughts yeah to some
degree that's probably accurate to some
degree that's probably accurate let me
say thank you to Kathleen Cushing who is
new member number six today at join
pakman.com Marty Gould is new member
number seven today at join pakman.com
Neal Moreau is new member number eight
today at join pakman.com and I'm pleased
to see that the website seems to be
coming back up oh I'm getting so weave
height we have an emerge web master has
I have people and then she has people
and she has her people working on it and
I'm getting a message saying working on
keeping the website up right now I am
going to set up HTML caching as well to
get that going
all right so people are working people
are working on this very very
aggressively very strongly I should
so hopefully oh the website just came
back up for me so that's good
let's I'm glad people were able to very
very quickly start start working on that
let me say a few twitch thank-yous let
me see here
battle-ready Carter has subscribed with
prime I am sim bloom has subscribed with
prime NYX the latter has subscribed with
prime and says thanks for all the hard
work David crux junkie has subscribed RG
blanchard and dirt nap both have
subscribed and I am computer has sent a
cheer which I very much appreciate ok
today's press briefing was scheduled for
5:00 p.m. Eastern Time we're now 16
minutes past that we don't know when it
will start they always start late
sometimes 40 minutes late sometimes 5
minutes late we still don't really know
why if you're just joining me on YouTube
do me the small favor of hitting like
and subscribe that really helps YouTube
recommend more people come to this
stream as opposed to others and a thanks
to you guys very importantly we have
surpassed eight hundred and twenty
thousand subscribers on YouTube which is
nuts absolutely crazy so make sure to
use use the like and subscribe buttons
Dave Matthews says have you talked about
the new Joe Biden's allegation we have
somewhat and it's a fluid situation so
to speak so expect more about it super
illumines says heard about the u.s.
hijacking masks from france i have not I
have not heard about that Vasile Vanda
has subscribed on youtube the breaker of
walls says hell yeah do a video on the
10k relief for kovat 19 a little
something to help stay start strong
David we need you Jason Ealing says best
presidents of the 20th century mine is
FDR I find it very fraught to try to
answer those questions number one
because very few people agree but also
you know the the needs and circumstances
of the United States were so drastically
different for eggs
in the progressive era of the 1920s
compared to during the 2008 recession
versus the post-world War 2 era so I am
you know I know it's really popular for
a lot of people to say these are the
best presidents of this era that era I
think it's actually really difficult
because circumstances required such
different things at different points in
American history let's see here
a DD says hey David I live in st. Pete
Florida I have a chance to move back to
Somerville Massachusetts in May do you
think Corona in Massachusetts will be
worse than Florida by then you know
based on the model let's take a look as
of right now Massachusetts is expected
to peak on April 17th Florida is
expected to peak on May 3rd because
Florida is very late to the game so my
guess is for both political and
mathematical reasons that Massachusetts
will be better off sooner than Florida
that's that's my instinct right now let
me say a big thank you to Gerry Silva
Gerry Silva is new member number 9 today
at join pakman.com thanks so much
Gerry also want to say thank you to
Julie Fraser whose new member number 10
Ryan Wenning is new member number 11 and
Jason Wiersma is new member number 12
today at join pakman.com it seems as
though the website is sort of holding so
this may be a good opportunity if folks
were having trouble signing up before -
maybe attempt to get one of those cool
membership things mr. L mr. lieutenant
pink says should countries have used
their militaries more it depends for
what you mean I'd need to know more
about sort of what you have in mind let
me see here lost a bunch of these hold
on here ok here we go
pair tieran says the anti-semite were
reported on secular talk sickening I'll
check that out
Matthew Lefevre says what are your
thoughts on the role of K through 12
education in the midst of the corona
crisis well I mean I don't know if you
mean like do I think schools should
reopen unfortunately the answer is no
and that's going to be complicated the
longer this goes but know for now if
you're asking me if I think like sixth
graders should start going to school now
no things have got to stay shut down for
the time being classy Andy says Time
magazine has a live feed on YouTube oh
let me pull that up I prefer to know
what's going on in the room you know
let's see here
time coronavirus live let's see if we
can get that feed going time I'm
actually having trouble finding that I
see yesterday's stream oh here it is
okay very good so we can keep an eye on
this for the time being leader and we'll
see what's happening in the room that'll
be a good thing here we go okay very
good
all right so there's John Roberts from
Fox News and people there people are
starting to file an excellent Hugh Jass
says David what are your IQ SAT and a CT
scores I don't know my IQ I never took
the AC any a CT the a CT test I think my
SAT score back in the era where 1600 was
a perfect score I think I had 1320 I you
know I I my parents are not from the US
I'm not from the US so we didn't really
understand the concepts of like studying
SAT prep or anything like that so I just
showed up and took the test once and I
got a 13 2013 10 and that was fine
enough for where I was going to school
so that was like it that was it Nicholas
Bauer says the SBA made it really simple
for the loan click the kovat bar on the
top of the page yeah I'll do a video in
a day or two about that Jericho Anderson
has grabbed a YouTube membership keep it
real cam says can Trump put off the
election and hold his position due to
the crisis so Donald Trump could
potentially
asked States to postpone the election
from November 6th the problem is that
electors are scheduled to cast their
ballots
I believe it's December 14th that's very
difficult to delay and if there's no new
president-elect by January 21 the
Speaker of the House becomes the
president so I don't think Trump wants
Nancy Pelosi to be President so I
wouldn't I wouldn't expect that I would
certainly would not be holding my breath
for that at this point in time okay let
me say thanks to Darren H for
subscribing with twitch prime very much
appreciate that
Lionel rich says we need people like you
and independent media so here's my super
chat to show my support can't go to the
pub so five-pound donation instead of a
pint is fine thanks Lionel I appreciate
that
Anthony par says Washington State has
bent the curve pretty well went from
third in cases to eighth in the US yeah
and even more relevant are the per
capita numbers which look even better
actually for Washington State
wow what kraits says nobody talking
about how the stimulus check is an
advance on next year's tax return if my
return is less than 1200 they keep my
return and I'll still oh I didn't read
that that's not what I've read so that
comes as news to me if that's the case
aquatic llamas says give Pakman 'like
for these streams yes thank you most
importantly on YouTube but if you're
watching on twitch make sure to follow
but most importantly on YouTube make
sure to LIKE the stream and hit the
subscribe button both extremely
extremely important
rofl what says good luck everybody
Austin egg Eamon says please go to the
IRS website with stimulus check
qualifications see which groups get 1200
I see most only getting 300 to 800
please help I'll bookmark that I don't
want I don't want to jump into that
right now but I will bookmark that and
then take a look just making a note to
myself
and I'll follow up about that for sure
okay
unknown prodigy says are you personally
getting any stimulus or help we we may
be getting the small business thing we
may be getting the small business thing
that has been allocated Luke booyah Vic
subscribes on YouTube Hugh Jass says
sell me to join Pakman why did you block
Alex Jones I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about and I would
listen the reason why it's important oh
we're getting some blurry video here the
reason why the best place to support us
is our website join pakman.com is
because that's where we keep the largest
share of every payment and all these
other platforms you know YouTube Twitter
etc they take bigger slices on our
website we just pay 2.9 percent and we
keep the rest because we're swiping
credit cards so that's why that's why
the website is the best and I am getting
another report that the website is back
up and that join pakman.com should
should indeed be working Jeff Richardson
upgraded his membership to beta Alvin
says David you're claimed that Joe
Biden's mental decline is less severe
than that of trumps is simply false this
is obvious for everyone who pays
attention yeah you know I've spoken to
five combination of five neurologists
and mental health professionals and none
of them believe that what's going on
with Joe Biden is as severe as what
appears to be going on with Trump I am
you know my opinions are relevant I'm
not a neurologist I'm not a mental
health expert I simply go to the experts
and the five I've spoken to believe that
it is not the same I you know it's not
my area of expertise Elvin says day oh
that's the same thing okay friendly-fire
says David eight hundred and twenty
thousand subscribers is astonishing
congratulations well thank you it's
because of you guys
that we have eight hundred and twenty
thousand subscribers gpw ap2
where'd that go says where did echo
David please please please very briefly
look up this lawsuit Parsa vs. Google
it's mind-blowing ok I'll do that but
you know I don't want to do it on stream
because I don't know what's awaiting me
there
FDR imprisoned the Japanese no one is
perfect no one is perfect that's true
Rasmus Hamaker says old man's flu 50%
Dutch intensive care is people under 50
Wow let's see so we've gotten the video
here on the time Channel has gotten very
blurry oh there we go now it's back to
hi-def very good nanny of many says wash
hands and stay safe David and all Maddy
ice says do a live show in Providence
it's weird seems like a light just went
on behind me anybody noticed that those
really odd but all the lights seem like
they've been on the whole time
odd there are no live shows anytime soon
as many of you can probably imagine no
live shows happening anytime soon but at
some point they will there will be live
shows again Bradley Ward says my sister
nurse was told to use a bandana for a
mask yeah it's better than nothing I
mean listen all of these pieces of
fabric are just lattices and you know
with an n95 mask I believe the lattice
leaves a three micron gap with a bandana
or a scarf it's just a different sized
lattice and it's everything's better
than nothing but obviously health
workers need and 95 masks of course
Kowalski from Nebraska says thanks to
the current level of staggering manpower
shortage I'm able to make about 900
bucks a day so I'm gonna keep sharing
some love also no beef until this is
over stay sane everyone thanks Kowalski
appreciate that Ryan nawicki says I
looked at your site and suggests
separating your signup page from the
site to keep customers from slowing down
potential ones and vice versa yeah we're
doing everything we can with the
website but you know what I think we're
gonna have a meeting of the minds after
today's stream with my team so that we
can keep the website up and running it
it sort of seems to keep crashing and
I'm gonna send another message here
let's see see what's going on okay yeah
the team is working on it but it's all
it's all getting very very ugly just due
to the demand on the website everybody's
working on it we have a full team
working on it at this point in time
henrik Mullen says love your coverage
love from Denmark
thanks Henrik beetle Greg says hi David
do you think Argentina can win the World
Cup in 2022 you know I have to tell you
I've not given it any thought I am not
thinking that far ahead at this point in
time James Buchi no says David do you
believe distance-learning for K through
12 will be as effective as learning in a
real classroom you my instinct is that
it's not going to be as effective and I
have a lot of friends who are teachers
and they they seem to agree but yeah I
don't I don't think it will be as
effective at least not in the immediate
Brian Wagner sends a super chat
Stephanie Wagoner sends a super chat
Jared cam Barrow says David after kovat
19 will the House Democrats seek
accountability on Trump's missteps or
inaction if these otherwise result in
more deaths I well Adam Schiff already
said he wants like a bipartisan panel
investigating I don't know what anybody
will be able to achieve we're gonna have
to deal with that in the post-mortem if
that if that makes sense
Jonathan says David do you think we will
see more investment scandals by
opportunists like burr and Trump before
this is all over yes will there be any
real consequences for it probably not
probably not Oh what's going on here
this is interesting they're opening up a
panel I've never seen this before
is this what allows them to pull the
TV's out somebody maybe asked for the
TVs
it's like a Wow look at this guy's
visibly struggling with whatever those
panels are interesting art we'll keep an
eye on that
Dave Matthew says this Trump actually
think Canadians are crossing illegally
militarizing the border rule will only
stop Americans from illegally coming
into Canada at this point I have no idea
what Donald Trump actually believes
about that I really couldn't tell you
Charlie says is the weather bad in DC or
did Trump move things back indoors
because the wind messed up his wig I
think the last couple days have been
colder than Sunday Monday when he did
the outdoor briefings rusty Osgood sends
a ten dollar super chat thanks rusty
Marty Gould says what are the details on
the chess tournament no decision yet we
did a chess tournament last week and
over 500 people played and it was
fantastic
and people are asking for more frequent
chess tournaments and we're going to see
we I some part of me thinks I'll just do
one on a whim tomorrow night and see who
plays but usually we want to announce it
ahead of time so more likely I might
announce one for next week and then you
know I think that'll probably get more
more people playing let's see here Jake
semi er says is there any reason why
2020 now code is invalid while trying to
sign up no reason no it's it's valid and
people are using it so III think it's
probably case sensitive and you're
typing it all with capital n o WN o w I
think it needs to be lowercase n o W
that's probably part of it let's see
I'll try it right now because the
website is back up it's working for me
2020 now is working for me I would make
sure that you're not typing it with caps
Polly Bird has grabbed the You Tube
membership Anderson uwp says does de
Blasio bear any responsibility he was a
hard denier as well yeah de Blasio too
late in the game was telling people to
go to restaurants and you know Thea
or whatever so but de Blasio certainly
bears some criticism for sure Ben Rowan
says hi from locked-down New Zealand I
watch you everyday and love your work
keep it up thank you very much
Anderson says this the blow okay that's
a duplicate and also says did you see
The Washington Post mashup of his
comments I did I did and it's not good
get a grip has upgraded their membership
to beta Moshe has upgraded their
membership to beta we have military
today oh we have William bar chief
propagandist or one of the top ones a
lot of military brass as they call it
looks like was that Kelly on Conway
there on the left let me say thank you
to Dan Sizemore who is new member number
13 today at join pakman.com Jeffrey dem
ra is new member number 14 Cheryl K is
new member number 15 the website is
coming alive my friends I'm glad people
are able to sign up it was really grim
there for about a half hour
these folks are all standing way too
damn close like what are these big what
on earth are these people doing
incredible everybody's gonna be infected
soon Nate Brody says South Korea and the
u.s. first cases occurred on the same
day yeah I think it was off by one day
here's Trump let's take a listen
so America continues to wage you all out
let's look for a louder louder feed
[Music]
thank you so America continues to wage
you all-out war to defeat the virus this
horrible horrible virus you see how
terrible it is especially when you look
at the numbers from yesterday and we
explained why we're extending our
nationwide guidelines to slow the spread
for 30 days together tell you I don't
feel great about so many military people
up on the stage I have a bad feeling
about what's coming social distancing
economic support for our workers rapid
medical intervention and very serious
innovation and banning dangerous foreign
travel that threatens the health of our
people and we did that early far earlier
than anyone would have thought and way
ahead of anybody else in this time of
need I know that every American will do
their patriotic duty and help us to
achieve a total victory as governments
and nations focus on the coronavirus
there's a growing threat that cartels
criminals terrorists and other malign
actors will try to exploit this
situation for their own gain and we must
not let that happen so this is from
literally setting this up with even more
warlike imagery it states is launching
enhanced counter narcotics operations in
the Western Hemisphere to protect the
American people from the deadly scourge
of illegal narcotics scourge we must not
let the drug cartels exploit the
pandemic to threaten American lives
in cooperation with the 22 partner
nations u.s. Southern Command will
increase surveillance disruption and
seizures of drug shipments and provide
additional support for eradication
efforts which are going on right now at
a record pace we're deploying additional
Navy destroyers combat ships aircraft
and helicopters Coast Guard cutters and
water force surveillance aircraft
doubling our capabilities in the region
very importantly our forces are fully
equipped with personnel protective
equipment and we've taken additional
safety measures to ensure our troops
remain healthy secretary mark s /
Attorney General Bill Barr national
security advisor Robert O'Brien will
provide more details in addition I'm
going to have general Milley who's done
an incredible job literal gas Lighting's
say a few words and also with us our
Chief of Naval Operations Admiral Gil
day who you know I think you know and
Commandant of the Coast Guard Admiral
Shultz so I'm gonna ask mark to start
and then we can go and after that we're
gonna take questions as it pertains to
this and then we'll go on to phase 2
which is the virus itself oh dear the
Uglies total propaganda going on here
guys
well thank you mr. president and good
afternoon everyone I appreciate the
opportunity to be here today as we make
this very important announcement at a
time when the nation and the department
defense are focused on protecting the
American people from the spread of the
corona virus we also remain vigilant to
the many other threats our country faces
today at the president's direction the
Department of Defense in close
cooperation with our interagency
partners began enhanced
counter-narcotics operations in the
eastern Pacific Ocean and the Caribbean
Sea can you imagine this initiative is
part of the administration's
whole-of-government approach to
combating the flow of illicit drugs into
the United States and protecting the
American people from their scourge yeah
that's what we need to do I want to
thank all of our partners in this effort
to include the United States Coast Guard
the
Department of Homeland Security the Drug
Enforcement Agency the Department of
Justice and members of the intelligence
community for the tremendous support and
cooperation to conduct these enhanced
operations the president has directed
the deployment of additional ships
aircraft and security forces to the
United States Southern Command area of
responsibility
included in this force package our Navy
destroyers and littoral combat ships
Coast Guard cutters p8 patrol aircraft
and elements of an army security force
assistance of gays these additional
forces will nearly double our capacity
to conduct counter narcotics operations
in the region
additionally 22 partner nations have
joined us in this fight bring with them
a variety of intelligence and operations
capabilities needed to defeat these
criminal organizations last year alone
United States southern commands
operations resulted in the seizure of
over 280 metric tons of drugs most of
which was designated for shipment to
America while this was an incredible
achievement there is much more work to
be done transnational criminal
organizations continue to threaten our
security by smuggling cocaine fentanyl
methamphetamines and other narcotics
across our borders these drug
traffickers put our communities
communities at risk and destroy lives
every year tens of thousands of
Americans die from drug overdose and
thousands more suffer the harmful
effects of addiction furthermore corrupt
actors like the illegitimate Maduro
regime in Venezuela rely on the profits
derived from the sell narcotics to
maintain their oppressive hold on power
the Venezuelan people continue to suffer
tremendously due to Maduro as criminal
control over the country my door drug
traffickers are seizing on this
lawlessness by increasing their illicit
activities we must do more to prevent
these drugs from arriving at our shores
these enhanced counter narcotics
operations that are now underway will
further disrupt the flow of illicit
drugs
to America deny our adversaries the
financial resources they depend on and
build the capacity of our partner
nations throughout the region I want to
thank President Trump for his leadership
and support to this critical mission
this is particularly important time for
this operation to begin as nations
around the world shift their focus
inward to deal with the corona virus
pandemic
many criminal organizations are
attempting to capitalize on this crisis
the enhanced operations we are
announcing today will keep the pressure
on these criminal groups and protect the
American people from the devastation
caused by the flow of illegal drugs into
our country can you imagine mr.
president thank you for your leadership
as we begin this important operation
while the men and women of the United
States military work hard here at home
to fight the coronavirus we continue to
take action around the world to defend
our great country thank you and I like
to invite general Milley website is up
by the way for folks waiting to say
Thank You secretary for those words and
Thank You mr. president for your
leadership and I want to publicly thank
I have no Craig Fowler the commander of
u.s. Southern Command out of Miami for
leading this operation which is underway
effective today offering also Admiral
Gill day the Chief of Naval Operations
Admiral Schultz for their contributions
to this from their services this
thousands of sailors Coast Guardsmen
soldiers airmen Marines involved in this
operation we came upon some intelligence
some time ago that the drug cartels as a
result of KO vid 19 we're going to try
to take advantage of this situation and
try to infiltrate additional drugs in
our country as we know that 70,000
Americans died on an average annual
basis to drugs that's unacceptable we're
at war with kovat 19 we're at war with
terrorists and we are at war with the
drug cartels as well this is the United
States military and will not penetrate
this country you will not get past Jump
Street you're not going to come in here
and kill additional Americans and we
will marshal whatever assets are
required to prevent your entry into this
country to kill Americans so right now
the Navy has marshaled additional gray
all ships from both Paycom and you come
and for the naval fleet at Norfolk and
they are set sail already and they are
in the Caribbean right now addition to
that there's ten Coast Guard cutters and
there's special operations forces and
security force assistance brigades along
with Air Force reconnaissance aircraft
the bottom line is you're not going to
get through now is not the time to try
to penetrate the United States with
illegal drugs to kill Americans with the
United States military we will defend
our country regardless of the cost Thank
You mr. president
Wow completely toxic propaganda
Thank You mr. president thanks for your
decisive leadership as we confront this
unprecedented challenge posed by Corona
coronavirus yeah I'd like to thank you
for your support for this important
initiative and thank all of the
Secretary of Defense and all the
services for taking on this this
important initiative obviously during
this crisis we're all focused above all
else on covin 19 but at the same time
our law enforcement and national
security work must go forward protecting
the American people from the full array
of threats for the Department of Justice
one of our highest priorities must
remain destroying the Mexican cartels
their trafficking is largely responsible
for the deaths as we all know now of
70,000 Americans a year and also the
cause I wonder how many of those deaths
would be avoided by decriminalizing and
legalizing marijuana I wonder how many
of our national treasure as state
budgets are crushed by the burden that
this the this narcotic trafficking
causes the president has made clear that
we are in this fight against the cartels
to win and that we are not interested in
half measures and that the threat posed
by the cartel is not just a
law-enforcement threat but a national
security threat as well and in December
building on your success with the
Mexican president we're just a
cooperative relationship in the area of
immigration you asked me to go down and
meet with the president Lopez Obrador
and our exit can counterparts to see if
we could also establish a more
comprehensive and coordinated effort
with the Mexicans in confronting the
cartels understand that this is called
the coronavirus press briefing and Trump
scheduled discussions and currently have
an array of activities underway against
the cartels and we anticipate of
the Mexicans that these are going to
bear fruit in the months ahead but it
quickly became clear that we can obtain
the most immediate results the best bang
for the buck where we increase the
assets involved in interdiction on both
the Pacific and Atlantic side of Mexico
and the Central American countries for
years the cartels have been using these
sea routes to take the cocaine up from
principally Colombia now also at of
Venezuela and these sea routes on both
coasts have become the primary means of
bringing cocaine up to the United States
because of the superb work done by the
Defense Department and our intelligence
community we know exactly most of the
time where these traffickers are at sea
but were significantly have been up till
now significantly limited in our ability
to interdict because of the numbers of
the assets we have deployed prior today
or this limitation meant we could only
intercept the fraction of the
traffickers that we and the various
boats that were detected this will now
double our capacity and we are talking
about hundreds of tons of cocaine now
we're now in a position to seize so this
is going to radically improve our
interdiction efforts and put tremendous
pressure we think on the cartels and the
effort that SOUTHCOM is undertaking is
going to save lives by should we even be
listening to this this has nothing to do
with coronavirus this this is just you
know military propaganda essentially in
misdirection crimes against the former
adoro
regime 16 members of that regime and
their involvement in trafficking of 250
metric tons a year a lot of that comes
by sea as I discussed at that time but
also because of the pressure we're
applying
by RC interdiction they are trying to
establish an air route out of Venezuela
up into Central America which is one of
the reasons we're trying to move firmly
against that corrupt regime
you know this drug war has gone on for
many decades and at times in the past
we've had great success and great
results and at times we've taken our eye
off the ball fortunately not in this
administration and I'm grateful that you
mr. president have brought focus to this
fight by people literally died of
coronavirus while they've been talking
about you know sending destroyers to the
Caribbean have to be defeated both for
the people of this country and for the
people of Mexico and Venezuela so I'd
like to thank you again mr. president
secretary Esper for providing the
wherewithal required to help win this
war against the cartels and others who
seek to send illicit drugs into our
country and with that I'd like to
introduce ambassador O'Brien oh great
that's just what we need
Thank You general Thank You mr.
president
today's action is another example of the
bold leadership of President Trump and
his commitment to protecting the
homeland against threats that seek to
destabilize the United States and our
Western Hemisphere the uncontrolled flow
of illegal drugs into the United States
poisons our communities fuels the
dangerous epidemic epidemic of addiction
and threatens the safety and security of
all Americans the impressive US Navy
Coast Guard Army Marine Corps Air Force
and interagency operation will address a
range of threats to our national
security posed by narco traffickers and
narco terrorists it will reduce illicit
financial support for the drug traffic
for drug trafficking that provides the
corrupt madero regime in Venezuela and
other bad actors with the funds
necessary to conduct their malign
activities under president Trump's
leadership we will continue to execute
our maximum pressure policy to counter
the Madero regime's malign activities
including drug trafficking and that this
operation will help to choke off the
funds that go to that corrupt regime
madero narco terrorists and criminals
should make no mistake that
even as we are working around the clock
to fight the spread of coronavirus we
will continue to execute the president's
counter-narcotics strategy we're working
on a number of important national
security priorities as we face this
public health crisis the United States
will continue to combat disinformation
and fake about the combat you're the
source of it world's largest oil
producers to address volatility in
global oil markets we will always
protect our servicemen and servicewomen
around the world including in Iraq and
Afghanistan I want the American people
to know that President Trump and vice
president Pence and their administration
are working tirelessly every day to
protect the health and well-being of
Americans and respond to the coronavirus
our adversaries should take note however
this president has a clear-eyed focus on
America's national security as security
interest and let me be clear it would be
a mistake a mistake with terrible
consequences for any adversary to
attempt to do us harm during this health
crisis or ever for that matter thank you
very much thank you mr. president
Christi do for you mr. president or
secretary Esper what has changed that is
allowing these assets to be deployed now
whereas general Barr said in the past
they were not going well for a long time
we've had a lot of drugs coming into our
country and it's not that it's increased
its we've probably got it down a little
bit but it's still a tremendous number
families are being ruined lives are
being ruined it's an incredible thing
especially as you're at this position
and the war on drugs guys nobody would
believe I see reports that nobody would
believe so I met with the group behind
me to all of them and we said what do
you think we can do and I think they can
introduce they think that we can stop it
before it gets to the shores and they're
coming from all over the place and we
have incredibly talented people so I
think I'm gonna let mark just give them
little bit of an answer to that but we
just want to see if we can stop a big a
good percentage of the drugs you are
seeing propaganda sort of iterated in
real time here matter prioritization the
president's giving us very clear
guidance on what's important to him and
protecting the American people and as
some of you know I've begun I began a
review months ago looking at all of our
different geographic combatant commands
and looking at where we can free up time
money and and resources to put in into
other endeavors in this case we had
scrutinized our inventory fairly closely
the Chairman Millie did a great deal of
work on this with with Admiral gilday
and we felt that there was no risk to
the fleet to our operations to free up
in this case naval ships we also freed
up aircraft and other assets to apply
them to this presidential priority and
of course the Coast Guard did the same
so it was a very good operation
understand that the worst coronavirus
gets the more insane they get we're now
the briefing is straight up about
sending ships to the Caribbean we're
gonna run it for some matter of time I'm
not gonna disclose how long it will be
and then we will assess it and then
we'll make adjustments from there we may
increase we may decrease we may sustain
as is but this will be an assessment we
will do as an interagency team we will
report back to the president and we'll
take further guidance from there I would
love it if no one asked any more
questions about this and forced them to
move on to talk about the virus so at
least for the next hopefully short
period of time the virus so we'll be
able to have an effect on that to expand
on that a little bit because you tie it
to Cove in nineteen saying that these
drug cartels we're taking advantage of
the situation
pandemic how exactly well because we're
focused on so many other parts of the
country and even parts of the world and
all of a sudden areas where we had it
clamped down pretty tight
well fairness you know the wall is up to
about a hundred and sixty miles already
and any areas where we have that wall
for the most part contiguous we have
fill-ins but we're up to one hundred and
sixty one miles exactly and any place
where you have that wall other than
walking around it on the edges it's
stopping everybody cold and with
stopping when nobody's seen anything
like yes the hundred miles on a 2,000
mile border unless you walk around it
it's stopping everybody sudden they
changed it's having a tremendous impact
but we are now focused on so many
different things because of what's
happened because of this horrible I say
it's a horrible phenomena that now we've
got to focus on drugs and the drugs come
in from different methods and we have
the best people that see anywhere in the
world so we'll have a tremendous impact
on drugs but one of the other things
will also have an impact we think on the
on the virus ambassador O'Brien did
China under report both the number of
cases and the death toll from the corona
virus good question if that's the case
mr. president what does that mean for
our relationship with China and your
relationship with President Xi well
number one I think the president has a
great relationship with President Xi and
we'd like to have a great relationship
with China unfortunately we're just not
in a position to confirm any of the
numbers that are coming out of China
there's no way to confirm any of those
numbers there's lots of public reporting
on whether the numbers are are too low
you've got access to those reports that
are coming out of Chinese social media
and and some of the few reporters that
are left in China we just have no way to
confirm any of those numbers thank you
we really don't know how do we know
whether they underreported reported
however they report but we had a great
call the other night we're working
together on a lot of different things
including trade they're buying a lot
they're spending a lot of money they're
giving it to our farmers they're paying
our farmers for the product so you know
we're gonna we're gonna go saying I
don't really care if they're lying about
the numbers they're giving us money it
earlier today that there was uncovered
intelligence that there was a sneak
attacks being planned against American
troops American assets in Iraq are we
talking about Thai but Hezbollah again
also we were saved but we just have
information that they were planning
something and it's very good information
it was led by Iran not necessarily Iran
but by groups supported by Iran but that
to me is Iran and we're just saying
don't do it don't do it yes but be a
very bad thing for them if they did it
last time they did do it in early March
can Taji
there was a response from the military
against time Hezbollah and five
Hezbollah alone very powerful response
by the way that response knocked out
five different places but it also took
out a lot of very bad people suggest
though that if it happens again it may
go up the future well that was a very
big response you know we knocked out a
lot we looked they hit one said we had
five big ones and ammunition sites you
saw that you saw what happened and I
won't say how many people were killed
but some bad people were killed and a
lot of them that was a big response but
this response will be bigger if they do
something yeah yes thank you mr.
president just going back to your
conversation with President Xi wondering
if you received an intelligence report
they talked about the discrepancy in the
numbers and if you address that with
we have not received that but their
numbers seemed to be a little bit on the
light side and I'm being nice when I say
that relative to what we witnessed and
what was reported but we discussed that
with him not so much the numbers as what
they did and how they're doing and we're
in constant communication with I mean I
would say the biggest communication is
myself and President Xi the
relationships very good we have look
they're spending they will be spending
when things even out this is obviously a
little bit of a hurdle what's happened
over the last month but there'll be
spending two hundred and fifty billion
dollars buying our product fifty billion
dollars to the farmers alone two hundred
billion dollars two other things they
never did that before so we have a great
trade deal and we'd like to keep it
they'd like to keep it then the
relationship is good as to whether or
not their numbers are accurate I'm not
an accountant from China anything at all
in terms of the trade deal no because
people just don't know people don't know
where did it come from I think we all
understand where it came from and
President Xi understands said we don't
have to make a big deal out of it we
didn't like the fact that they said it
came from our soldiers and they haven't
pursued that it was and that was a
mid-level person said that that was not
a high-level person so I assume I will
always assume the best I'll assume the
high-level people didn't know about it
it was a forward statement so look the
relationship with China is a good one
and my relationship with him is really
good Chinese propaganda that you
mentioned as well as
right so in the past several weeks China
has been shipping ppes you know maths
they're either been selling or donating
everywhere Africa Europe Italy Russia
and really pushing this narrative that
they're taking on a global leadership
role in the crisis so what are your
thoughts on that and is there any final
binders they want view that as a
positive if they're helping other
countries we have 151 countries right
now that are under siege by the virus
under siege some are doing really badly
score they don't know about social
distancing these are countries that
aren't highly sophisticated they don't a
great communication to the rest of the
world calling them savages the things
that we're doing and that some others
are able to do and if China can help
them I'm all for it I'm for all of us
helping everybody we're soon gonna have
more ventilators that we need we're
building thousands of ventilators right
now and now it takes a period of time to
build them understand we have shortages
right now
Pete places need them now he won't send
him from the stockpile he's bragging in
the future we'll have more than we need
is even after we stockpile for some
future catastrophe which we hope does it
happen we're gonna be distributing them
the extras around the world we'll go to
Italy we'll go to France we'll go to
Spain which is an you know very hard-hit
shipment of USAID stockpiles of BP's
abroad no it's we want
I would love China and other countries
if the front / fischels have admitted
that already it's guys just a liar
medical supplies to give to other
countries 150 150 why would I stop that
wouldn't it be terrible to stop it the
u.s. stopped a shipment of our own stuff
through USAID
other countries now whatever we have
whatever we've committed to we commit
but we also need a lot for ourselves so
we're very focused on that until we get
over this so obviously we're not going
to be shipping too much until now we do
have excess of certain things and we
don't have enough of others I just had a
great talk today with the Doug McMillon
from Walmart and I gave him a very very
big order to for sponsors for protective
gear for the doctors for the nurses for
everything and he's actually very
excited about it he's the biggest
purchaser of this horsey kind of thing I
mean of anything probably in the world
and he is very excited about it what an
accomplishment you got the Walmart's CEO
excited by giving them a big order these
hospitals the amount that they order you
almost say how could they possibly use
so much whether it's masks or the
protective gear but we are supplying a
tremendous amount and we just ordered a
lot from Walmart and he's taking this
one personally
and I said let it go ship let it be ship
not to a warehouse directly to the side
of the hospital or wherever they need it
because we save a lot of time when we do
that so Walmart in addition to many
other companies and people is now
involved at the highest level for being
the flow of narcotics in the country are
you concerned that we're possibly losing
ground from the drug crisis flour losing
bad but we don't want to lose ground
that's why we're doing it I don't want
to lose ground it's a big fight
I've seen many families where they're
wiped out because they lost the son or a
daughter or a husband or a wife or
whatever or all of them and we don't
want to lose ground and we are heavily
focused on the virus very heavily
focused and with this we have never
after this goes into effect which
essentially is now we will never have
been so focused on drugs coming into our
country as we are right now and remember
as that wall gets bigger that really
helps us a lot really helps us a lot yep
latin-american government working in
conjunction with this operation to help
with that project many of the
government's are and Mexico in
particular is in Mexico right now is we
have 27,000 Mexican soldiers or notice
he slips in like the wall as if it's
being built you know just casually drops
that in there people are coming into our
country right now and as we complete
again the wall
in addition 27,000 soldiers well it's
not good it's a very it's a very tough
place to come into when I when I took
over people were coming in and they were
bringing whatever they wanted they were
bringing drugs of any type and now it's
very hard for them and it will get
harder and harder but the President of
Mexico is a great guy who's really
helped us to go 27,000 soldier 27,000
Mexican soldiers and you remember when I
first took over they had all of the
caravans coming up with 10,000 15,000
people in the caravans they were
marching through Mexico that's not
happening anymore please in Colombia or
the Maduro regime do you know if they're
working in conjunction with the Mexican
cartels is there any intelligence
indicating that I cannot tell you that I
can I know the answer to that I believe
I do but I cannot tell you this we have
information that would lead us to
believe something very powerfully but I
cannot tell you what please we believe
it very powerfully but I can't tell you
in Iraq taking any precautions because
this particular attack have you been
taken precaution
we are watching it very closely and if
something bad happens it's going to be
very painful for the other side then in
touch with the Iraqi government about
this they know about it but you know
we're down to a small force now over the
years since I got we've been bringing
smaller and smaller and we're done right
now to a small number but we have very
powerful airpower there we have the big
base and which will you know I mean
nobody can get near it and nobody can
even get near that but we've really
largely left you know we've taken
tremendous amounts out and we've
deployed them elsewhere including
bringing some back home and do you think
tweeting about it social media it gets
out I have you know hundreds of millions
of people number one on Facebook did you
know I was number one of Facebook and I
just found out I'm number one on
Facebook I thought that was very nice
represents something nice when I can
explain to people just don't do it you
know it's gonna be bad if you do it's
gonna be really bad and they don't need
to do it they have enough problems
Iran has enough problems without doing
that but we've been pulling back for
substantially over the last year in Iraq
and so you know that's the way it is
before you don't want to give the enemy
whoever that is in this case
heads up do you feel like maybe you did
no I'm just giving them a warning it's
not a heads up I'm giving them a warning
there's a big difference I'm saying if
you do anything to hurt our troops
they're gonna they're gonna pay a price
now they did last time you know as per
the question they did last time
is this like at the April Fool's press
conference and then the real one starts
in a few minutes
five massive major ammunition sites and
a lot of people went with it a lot of
bad people a lot of enemy went with it
and we didn't want to make a big deal
out of it but they paid a big price
they'll pay a much bigger price this
time if they do anything yeah
Gilda here perhaps we could ask a
question about what the plans are for
the Roosevelts or in terms of Roosevelt
we're making great progress in terms of
testing and also moving moving people
off the ship so in the past day or so
we've moved over a thousand that number
will increase to more than 2,700 by
Friday as we continue to increase the
testing as well and fly those samples
off so again after pretty pretty quickly
well should remain fully operational it
is fully operational now and will remain
so remains are you putting in place to
help mitigate the spread of virus among
servicemen and women before us before we
have any ships getting underway for
training exercises for deployments
they're spending for those sailors
spending 14 days in quarantine before
they underway we've increased the amount
of testing equipment as well as
physicians on board ships at sea
so we've taken additional steps since
the beginning of the people various
ports anymore
we probably decided on that I think
Trump thinks they're talking about a
cruise ship that did you notice that
did anybody did anybody catch that that
was a very confused look on the military
guy's face about there that we should
just shut down the entire United States
military and addressed the problem that
way that's not feasible we have a
mission our mission is to protect the
United States of America and our people
and so we live and working in cramped
quarters whether it's a an aircraft
carrier a submarine a tank a bomber it's
the nature of our business but the chain
of command has very clear guidance and
I'm confident between the commanding
officers and the senior non-commissioned
officers that are taking every
reasonable precaution to make sure we
practice as best we can social
distancing sanitizing environments etc
consistent with that mission and that's
what I trust Abdo today acting secretary
moly and all the other service chiefs
and service leaders to do and I'm
confident will do that because keep in
mind we have a job to do and we will
continue to do it defend the United
States of America mr. president you
mentioned the stockpile earlier The
Washington Post reported today that the
u.s. stockpile is nearly depleted of PPE
is that indication if so many times
we're sending it directly to hospitals
we don't want it to come to the
stockpile because then we have to take
it after it arrives and bring it to
various states and hospitals one of the
things and again we asked the states to
do this as much as possible many of the
states have people that whether it's
that or clothing they make clothing lots
of clothing and many of the different
states who said see if you can get it
directly from those manufacturers make a
deal we'll use the purchase act if we
have to on them they won't by the way so
many people are the spirit is incredible
what they're doing but we the core
states where they have large
manufacturers of different types of
equipment to use those local factories
those local plants and have it made
directly ship it right into the
hospitals we're shipping things right
and we have as you know almost 10,000
ventilators which we need for
flexibility it's a lot it sounds like a
lot but it's not because as you see on
the board from yesterday as this scourge
as this play gets scored virus moves it
moves very
fast and we don't know yet whether we're
gonna need it in Louisiana in New York
it would you know wherever it may be so
we're ready for it we're totally ready
for it we're gonna be shipping out we've
already agreed to ship out over a
thousand today to different sites
different locations but we have to have
the flexibility of moving the
ventilators to where to where the virus
is going and we'll be able to see that
you know we'll be able to see that from
charts a couple of days in advance so
right now we have a nice pile of
ventilators we have a lot more coming we
have a lot of I think we have 11
companies making ventilators right now
very good companies so the important
fact check is there are currently states
blue states that have asked for stuff
they still have not gotten from the
government and Trump says well everybody
has what they need and we're holding
stuff 15 minutes it's not a mask can go
quickly a ventilator takes time to build
it's very very as we discussed it's
complex it's big gets expensive you know
etc but we'll be able to move we have
great flexibility John I was just going
to say sir if you want to move on to
slowly coronavirus or yeah I think if
does anybody have any other questions
for this great so just so people know we
were expecting a coronavirus press
briefing and all these military people
came out and they announced that they're
sending ships in Venezuela and all of
this sort of stuff it's a total
disinformation propaganda it's
propaganda warfare essentially is what
we have here that's the war and we still
haven't even started the kovat press
briefing Thank You patience well excuse
me as you know we have the hospital
ships currently deployed one in LA and
one in New York City so they are they
will be they could be treating patients
as they come in we're taking
precautionary measures to screen them
beforehand to make sure that they're not
they're not exposed if you will same
with the military hospitals that we are
we are deploying certainly again to New
York Seattle and other places but the
one thing we got to be careful of where
we were is that these are deployable
assets they are unique so if we want to
retain the ability to deploy military
doctors expeditionary military hospitals
around the country we've got to preserve
and protect them as best we can that
said we remain completely available to
assist as need be as directed by FEMA
as the vice president and the president
asks us that's what we commit to do to
the American people to help safeguard
them and protect them through this
through this virus so far that they will
may be seen
Khurana buyers patients are they
strictly be seeing other patients and
helping they could have caught upon I
think the best use for them is based on
their training and how they're
structured and organized is for trauma
we can take the load off of hospitals
with regard to their trauma patients
thereby freeing up rooms and other
doctors particularly dr. z-- who are you
know respiratory nurses or doctors who
deal with infectious disease to treat
those type of patients so I think it's
the best use of our resources but again
if push comes to shove we're prepared to
do what we have to to to assist the
American people at the same time
preserving the Medicaid medical
capability we need to support our
operation deployed forces abroad
brand-new hospital ships because these
ships have really I mean they really
struck a blow very positive blow for
what they're doing going to Los Angeles
going into New York so we're looking
very seriously at building two
additional ships of about the same size
it'll either be bit well building but
we're looking at building either two new
ones we're doing the renovation of
another large ship but this has really
worked out well so probably two brand
new ones
this is concerning the gentlemen if you
want them you don't want them to get
back to work and capture all those big
people follow up mr. president or good
mr. secretary I know that secretary
Wilkie has said he's on standby waiting
to hear if VA hospitals need to be
opened the door need to be opened to
civilians who are you talking about that
should we see that happen happens in our
schools yeah sir I can move very quickly
he's a very capable man we're ready to
move very quickly as an example in
Louisiana they have a very big Hospital
so we're looking at move very quickly if
we need them you know hopefully we won't
need them we're gonna find out pretty
soon we're only gonna know when at the
time it happens we prepare for the worst
we are preparing for the worst that's
what you mately that's the way we have
to look at it feeding time up patient
and I'm just curious what about things
like you know giving birth what mothers
be expected and not doing that on the
ship that's the one thing they're not
doing outside of the cove at 19 they're
not doing that the birth of a baby not
being done on the ships okay can I have
a follow-up question with attorney
general barb please this this has to do
with the visa restriction of of
immigrants process administration
considering easing the restrictions for
waiving restrictions for doctors with j1
or h-1b visas so they can help other
doctors during this crisis
actually the immigration laws are no
longer under the administration of the
Department of Justice and I haven't been
participating any of those discussions
[Music]
this is on the topic of Iran the w-h-o
confirms that Iran is vastly under
reporting its coronavirus top agenda not
just cases but fatalities according to
on-the-ground estimates that it might be
as high as fifteen and a half thousand
well it's this woman it's you commanders
in the military in Iran are now
confirmed either in dire condition or
dead
you have 8% of the Parliament now a
virus so is Iran's soundings of
aggressions today that President Trump
just 17 so do you think strategically is
that a bluff on their part or is this a
sign of very clear desperation where are
you strategically on that well first and
foremost we empathize for the Iranian
people I mean they clearly have been hit
hard as you know I think the president
spoken about it certainly secretary
Pompeo we've offered assistance we've
offered medical supplies etc they have
refused that I think if the Iranian
regime put more interest in terms of
taking care of their people and in in
the context of this virus they would be
better served instead the Iranian regime
continues to want to spread its malign
activities throughout the region they
want to continue to send out the Kurds
force and others to to cause problems
throughout the region we know that in
one way shape or form they are the
resourcing directing approving of
whatever operations for Shia militia
groups in Iraq that are targeting
American forces so I think at the end
the day again I feel a deep concern for
the Iranian people what the important
thing is the Iranian government should
focus on them and stop this malign
behavior that they've been conducting
now for over 40 years
I think the entire region and certainly
the Iranian people would be better off
for it
look at that when I make a deal they
just don't know really how to start and
they've been given some bad advice by
former secretary Kerry it's a very bad
advice oh dear I really think they want
to make a deal which is the Logan Act
but we'd have to look at the Logan Act
all you have to do is take a look I
think they've been given very bad advice
by secretary Kerry I think that I think
they're dying to make a deal look their
country's in trouble their economics are
shot there and they've got a lot of bad
things going I think they'd like to make
a deal they can get it settled very
quickly no nuclear weapons no real
weapons they can't have nuclear weapons
it's very simple okay let's let these
folks get back to work is that okay
thank you all very much so now they are
about to start the coronavirus press
briefing it hasn't even started yet
which is incredible here's Kelly Anne
Conway it's it's incredible I guess now
we're gonna soon get to maybe Trump is
just staying out I guess to do Corona
now so as we deploy our servicemembers
to combat both threats abroad invisible
enemy at home earlier today I spoke to
our nation's incredible warriors and
military families spent a long time on
the phone with thousands and thousands
of families that were hooked in in order
to stop the spread of the virus some of
these families have delayed planned
moves to their next duty station and in
other cases military families are also
waiting longer to welcome home the
heroes from deployment there's a
tremendous burden to bear and the
families have been involved with us for
so long and they are incredible without
the families they couldn't be a great
service members that they turned out to
be and they understand that and I must
say protecting our military families is
our top priority so they understand what
their what's happening with respect to
the virus and they understand it well
they've been fantastic as commander in
chief I'm deeply grateful for our
servicemembers their spouses and their
children whose love devotion and
sacrifice keeps America
strong to make procure and deliver
crucial
medical supplies to our doctors nurses
and healthcare workers my administration
is leveraging the might of American
manufacturing supply chains and
innovators across the industry and of
course every industry and I just told
you about Walmart and I could tell you
about many more Hanes is making
protective gear and mass means
tremendous amounts of product there's
never been anything like it at the same
time I tell the governor's get it
yourself if you can from your local
companies and your local warehouses and
factories if you can do that you should
do that
because of the actions that we've taken
under the defense production act
manufacturers and suppliers are sharing
with FEMA and HHS their planned orders
and allocations to States and to
hospitals all over the region this
enables FEMA and HHS to work closely
with States local governments and
private sector to allocate critical
resources to highly impacted areas
working together we're entirely focused
on getting materials to the right place
at the right time so we wanted to go
directly to a hospital or directly to a
certain state location it does look like
pence is wearing a hat doesn't it the
states warehouses if we can avoid the
warehouses it's even better because they
go directly into a hospital and one
example of that is Ohio the great state
of Ohio senator Rob Portman called today
and he asked for some help and got us
did a tremendous job along with Mike
DeWine the great governor of Ohio to
facilitate a donation of 2.2 million
gowns 2.2 million yes think of what that
is 2.2 million to the strategic national
stockpile from Ohio based Cardinal
Health Cardinal health we appreciate it
and they're making much more than that
and different types of things
we're profoundly grateful for their
contribution to protect the lives and
safety of our healthcare professionals
Cardinal has been working with us
very well FEMA and HHS formed a historic
partnership with the private sector
called project air bridge to bring
supplies from other countries to the
United States including gloves gowns
goggles and masks these supplies will
soon be distributed around the country
we have large cargo planes coming in
from various parts of the world every
day new plane loads are landing in
cities such as New York Miami Chicago
Los Angeles additional flights have been
scheduled and we're adding more and more
and they're actually coming in ahead of
schedule a lot of these flights are
coming in with a lot of material ahead
of schedule the amount of usage the
amount of need is something that
nobody's ever seen before we are getting
so much but no matter how much we get
they seem to use it up very quickly more
than 17-thousand National Guard
personnel have now been activated all
across our country on Tuesday the vice
president sent a letter to the
governor's calling on them to have plans
in place to use the National Guard to
move medical supplies from warehouses to
hospitals so a lot of times we'll
deliver supplies to a warehouse in a
state someplace in New York or in New
Jersey or in Connecticut or wherever it
may be and they're having difficulty
getting his move so what we're doing if
we don't bring it directly to the
hospital is we've authorized it was a
special authorization the National Guard
to go into that facility and to move it
for the state so the National Guard is
moving a lot of this equipment and
medical supplies into a hospital or into
an area where it's needed by the state
as I said yesterday difficult days are
ahead for our nation we are going to
have a couple of weeks starting pretty
much now but especially a few days from
now that are going to be horrific but
even in the most challenging of times
Americans do not despair we do not give
in to fear we pull together we persevere
and we overcome and we win this week
every American hardest
with the people of New York as they
continue to bear the brunt of the
pandemic every New Yorker please know
that we are by your side I Love New York
and every day we will be with you and it
could very well be that others take over
from New York there are some areas some
hotspots in other states that are really
exploding some like Louisiana were very
late and then all of a sudden it was
like an explosion yes in confront -
deadly plague America is armed with
capabilities never dreamed of in past
centuries you look at 1917 the pandemic
it was something ravaged parts of this
country but ravaged Europe ravaged they
say seventy five to a hundred million
some people say fifty to seventy-five
million people died think of that and
that was a long time ago over a hundred
years ago very very many books written
about the 1917 1918 pandemic none of
which is my doctors are poring over the
virus genetic code designing potential
therapies and vaccines our planes are
airlifting supplies from every corner of
the earth we're watching other countries
and they're watching us to see whether
or not and who's going to be the first
to come up with a cure or a remedy of
some kind or even a help if it can help
and of course a vaccine we're looking
very strongly for a vaccine Johnson &
Johnson is doing well and other
companies are doing very well but our
most powerful asset our greatest weapon
in this effort is the spirit of our
people and we want to keep away keep a
distance keep away if you don't get it
it solves a lot of problems if you don't
get it and you can't get it if you keep
the distance American spirit is
unyielding unwavering and unbreakable
it's incredible
I've never seen anything like it the way
the way the people have pulled together
the you
of this country so together we're going
to win this war and the sooner we do the
sooner we can begin to rebuild and we're
ready to rebound and return to normal
lives we work for the best economy in
the history of the world the best
economy that this country has ever seen
the best employment numbers we've ever
had 160 million people working almost a
hundred and sixty million to a point
where the professionals came to me and
they say sir you're gonna have to shut
the country down I said what does that
mean they said so you're gonna have to
shut it down sir but still and we're
gonna build it up and I think we're
gonna build it up fast I think we're
gonna have a tremendous rebound there's
a great energy and a great pent-up
demand and as you know phase 3 was
terrific and phase 4 what passed in
Congress and phase 4 if that happens
will be great I already proposed a
paying almost zero interest on bonds and
I proposed a two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan which would not only
fix our roads and highways and bridges
and tunnels and other things but will
also do something very good it's called
the jobs I'm also asking that
restaurants and entertainment facilities
go back to the old deductibility from
corporations where corporations can buy
because otherwise a lot of these
restaurants are gonna have a hard time
reopening it takes a long time and
they're gonna have a hard time reopening
so we're asking for going back to
deductibility where corporations can buy
and corporations can go out to lunch and
they pay and they get a deduction and
what they eat they get a deduction on
the bill and he barely understands that
same with the entertainment it's gonna
bring a lot of people back I think it'll
open up the restaurant business people
forget that years ago they had that and
when they got rid of it when they ended
it for whatever reason but they ended it
many many restaurants went out of
business many entertainment type
facilities went out of business and now
is a great time to bring it back it was
it was a terrible time for that business
after they ended it but this is a great
time to bring it back it'll keep our
restaurants let it I think the
restaurant business will be actually
bigger and better than it is right now
so we're also talking about that and now
what we'll do is we'll take some
questions and I see Mike is back with
some of the folks that's great dr.
pouchy and we will so we'll take some
questions and we make progress day by
day please listen seems to recognize the
people on the stage that's a start a
friend you had who is in a coma I'm
sorry but you said this is no flu
there's still some people to kind of
think of this as the flu and over the
past months you've compared it to the
flu sometimes saying treat it like the
flu or you know what treated hail we
handle the flu so that's changed your
thinking on that well you're very I
think also and looking at the way the
contagion the it is so contagious
nobody's ever seen it all of which we
these were large groups of people all of
a sudden just by being in the presence
of somebody having the flu has never
been like that and there is a flu is
contagious but nothing like we've ever
seen here also the violence of it if if
it hits the right person and you know
what those stats are if it hits the
right person that person is in deep
trouble and my friend was the right
person when you heard about that with
your friend like was that a turning
point well not at any point no before
then I knew how
because I'm seeing numbers that I'm
seeing statistics that you know not
exactly mr. president you said he'd be
gone by April like a miracle would you
care to take that back and acknowledge
how irresponsible it was kind of a guy
but he's older he's heavier and he's
sort of central casting for what we're
talking about and it hit him very hard
I've never seen anything like it yeah
John mr. president
and maybe this is question as well for
dr. Burks or dr. Falchi Senator Lindsey
Graham tweeted last night we checked
today that there are still flights that
are running between hot spots like New
York and Detroit New Orleans as well a
number of flights were completed today
Senator Graham's point is if you're
going to declare mitigation should it
not be full mitigation and you stop
people from travel we're thinking about
doing that at the same time we kissed
you know to start these airlines and to
start this whole thing over again is
very tough John it's very tough and you
have them going in some cases from hot
spot to hot spot if you notice they're
usually hot spot the huts but very few
flights New York to Miami and but where
we're thinking it we're certainly
looking at it but what you do that you
really are you really are clamping down
an industry that was desperately needed
calculation as to whether or not you you
keep the indoor going or your risk
spreading to change that is a
calculation that we're looking at right
now we're looking at it very strong
Tony's got a program do that mr.
president not every governor has issued
a stay at home order all of you have
made it very clear how important it is
to stay home that we are in a dire
situation here and that's how you stop
the spread is staying home why not take
what I got Kyra Phillips these two are
married and pretty is that actually Kara
Phillips I've met her before I'm pretty
sure she's married to John Roberts
different and I understand that governor
of Florida great governor Ron de santis
issued one today and that's good that's
great but there are some states that are
different there are some states that
don't have much of a problem there is
some well they don't have the problem
they don't have thousands of people that
are positive with thousands of people
that even think they might have it or
hundreds of people in some cases so you
have to look you have to look at that
stage you have to give a little bit of
flexibility but every state in the
Midwest or if Alaska has an example
doesn't have a problem it's awfully
tough to say close it down
so we have to have a little bit
flexibility look we're helping governors
we're really here to help governor's
they're the front line of attack and
that includes in purchasing by the way
we're here and we're backing them up and
there's never been a backup like we've
given them we're giving them billions of
dollars worth of things medical supplies
and ventilators thousands and thousands
of ventilators we have thousands under
construction right now we have thousands
ready to go in case they need it's never
been anything like this I mean we've
they've done really the people have done
incredibly we're building hospitals all
over the country we're building
hospitals right now at a rate that has
never even been contemplated before
they're mobile hospitals but they're
really not mobile I mean they're
incredible structures but we're building
many hospitals Louisiana New Jersey New
York we just finished a massive hospital
complex and we also have medical centers
built in New York we're building
hospitals at the rate that this country
has never done before and hopefully it's
all gonna work out this mr. president
just want to make sure we're clear on
their planes are you looking to just
curtailing routes between certain
hotspots or is it broadly well we're
looking at the whole thing because we're
getting into a position where we want to
do that we have to do that and so we'll
look at it the whole thing second
question on economics just with oil oil
prices are very low the saudis of
increased production i know ii spoken
about liking low oil prices but then
there's also the industry aspect from
1950 these are all pressures and that's
when they had big dollars big beautiful
dollars for you do you advocate cuts do
you advocate cuts to production to you
well look we have a great oil industry
and the oil industry is being ravaged
and as you know Russia and I spoke to
President Putin we had a great call
Russia Saudi Arabia I spoke with a crown
prince we had a great call but beautiful
perfect fun I think that they will work
it out over the next few days if you ask
me I think it's just it's too simple not
to be a
- they both know what they have to do so
I think I have confidence in both that
they'll be able to work it out but it's
it has ravaged an industry worldwide dot
yeah I mean worldwide the oil industry
has been ravaged so there was a lot of
oil production to start off with and
then on top of it it got hit with the
virus and business went down 3540
percent so that that business is a tough
one and you know they have ships all
over the sea I told you yesterday all
over to see massive tankers that they're
using for storage they go out and they
just sit there there's no place to go
they have massive amounts now gasoline
is gonna be 99 cents a gallon and less
you know that that's already starting
it's popping up 99 cheap gas can't drive
anywhere it's like like a tax cut to
people of our country when we try and
get the airlines going if if fuel is
costing much less it helps with getting
the airlines which is always a tough
business always has been a tough
business but with that being said look
I'm I want to get that industry back
where was we were doing records in that
industry also we want to get it back to
where it was so I think that Saudi
Arabia Russia they're negotiating
they're talking and I think they'll come
up with something I'm gonna meet with
the oil companies on Friday right not
really the independent oil producers
also on Friday or Saturday maybe Sunday
but we're having a lot of meetings on it
I think I know what to do to solve it
but if if they were unable to solve it
then I think I know what to do it is so
now but it's it's tough I think I know
what to do to solve it we don't want to
lose our great oil companies you know
with a number-one producer of oil in the
world
love and love oil I'm gonna go when you
said that it was great today when you
say it it's not so meaningful but I do
believe there's a way that that can be
solved or pretty well solved and I'd
rather not do that I think that Russia
and Saudi Arabia at some point they're
gonna make a deal in the not too distant
because it's very bad for Russia it's
very bad for Saudi Arabia that's very
bad I mean it's bad for both so I think
they're gonna make a deal you know the
free market is a wonderful thing it's
amazing how it can work but I think
they're gonna make a deal yeah you won
for mr. wolf as possible over five
million immigrants in this country do
pay taxes through their IT numbers yet
they will not receive any money in their
stimulus package I know undocumented
immigrants we've received any aid from
the government during this crisis how do
you suppose they survive during the
copic 19 well you know you're seeing
undocumented meaning they came in
illegally and a lot of people would say
we have a lot of citizens right now that
won't be working so well what happens to
agriculture for example a thing it's a
very terrible it's a very sad question I
must be honest with you but they came in
illegally and we have a lot of people
that are citizens of our country that
won't be able to have jobs now I do
think once we get rid of the virus I
think we're gonna have a boom economy I
think it's gonna go up rather quickly
maybe very quickly and maybe slowly but
it's going to go up and it'll all come
back and I think it's actually going to
come back stronger than what it was
because of the stimulus but it's it's a
really sad situation and we are working
on it I will tell you I'm not gonna give
you a hard and fast answer because I
just want to tell you it's something I
think about and it's something we're
working on please thanks mr. president
moving beyond when we're on the other
side of this curve
are we looking at living with some sort
of social distancing guidelines
especially it essentially until there's
treatment or vaccine for example people
looking forward to the summer talk about
you know going to baseball games going
to concerts we have political
conventions over the summer are things
like that possible or safe without a
vaccine or treatment place yeah I think
if we get to the part of the curve that
dr. Burke showed yesterday when it goes
down to essentially no new cases no
deaths at a period of time I think it
makes sense that you're gonna have to
relax social distancing the one thing we
hopefully would have in place and I
believe we will have in place there's a
much more robust system to be able to
identify someone who's infected isolate
them and then do contact tracing because
if you have a really good program of
containment that prevents you from ever
having to get into mitigation we're in
mitigation right now that's what the
social and physical distancing is the
ultimate the ultimate solution to a
virus that might keep coming back would
be a vaccine in fact I was on the weekly
conference call with the whu-oh
sponsored group of all the health
leaders in the world who are dealing
with this and we all came to the
agreement that we may have cycling with
another season will be much better
prepared we likely will have
interventions but the ultimate
game-changer in this will be a vaccine
the same way a vaccine for other
diseases that were scourge us in the
past that now we don't even worry about
I mean the vaccine is is as I said it's
on target we're still in Phase one there
were three doses that we had a test
we've been through the first two doses
we're on the highest dose now when we
get that data it'll take a few months to
get the data - we all feel confident to
go to the Phase two and then a few
months from now we'll be in phase two
and I think we're right on target to the
ER a year to a year and a half human dr.
Burke's
either of you receive threats of any
kind or have you been given a security
detail given you've been out here every
day on camera speaking well I mean I
anything that has to do with security
detail I'd have to have you refer that
question to the Inspector General of HHS
he was a great basketball player did
anybody know he was a little on the
short side for the NBA but he was
talented he he won a game I read this
sir he won a game that was unwinnable
against a great team and his whole team
said we can't beat this team and he went
in they won the game right there was a
couple of years ago four years ago the
head never changes the attitude never
changes right he's a winner I don't want
to hit you with everything that's coming
along but a lot of people who are
watching television today heard from a
researcher named dr. Jacob Granville
who's come up with a potential antibody
therapy that he has given to you Sam red
just wanted to know if you know anything
about this well you might be able to
tell people at home about it you've seen
it you know John I'm I don't know
specifically this individual what
they're doing but I can tell you there's
a lot of activity that is centered
around a passive transfer of antibodies
in the form of convalescent plasma or
asthma the number is to get immune
globulin that you precipitate out of the
plasma and another is monoclonal
antibody it's based on the same
principle of a few have a protective
antibody passive transfer of that could
provide not only protection
prophylactically but also treatment this
is an old concept in fact immunology was
born decades and decades and decades ago
with the concept of giving passive
transfer of serum to an individual to
protect them from an infection so it's I
wouldn't be surprised if he and a number
of other people are pursuing this it's
the right thing to do
dr. pouchy at what point can we as a
country expect there to be a widespread
antibody to usually know exactly what
we're dealing this year question as well
as other questions such as you know I'm
working to do well or a deemed to be
healthy donate blood for exactly okay so
when you talk about anybody testing
there are a couple of things that you
want to do you want to find out if
someone has been infected and whether or
not they're gonna ultimately wind up
being protected antibody testing right
now
is not the first thing on our priority
it's something that we need to do is
testing to see if someone is infected it
is very important ultimately to be able
to get a feel for what the penetrance of
the infection was in society for a
number of reasons you get a better feel
of what the impact has been but also you
get a better feel of what the herd
immunity would be right so I can foresee
in the future that when we get the
facility which we'll have for sure I
mean ultimately you can get a test that
could do this reasonably easy and do the
kind of what we call zero surveillance
study this is very analogous that dr.
Burks and I were talking about that a
lot and that is back in the day when she
and I were both doing the hiv/aids
issues back when we first discovered the
virus in 83 and we had an antibody test
in 1985 we found out by the serial
surveillance represented seven different
populations that we were dealing with
the tip of the iceberg when we saw
individuals who were the ones who
actually got infected notice not like
this is the most interesting and
relevant stuff and both Pence and Trump
seem zoned out and like they can't wait
to get past it oh I foresee that we'll
have that same sort of information which
will be important information but right
now that's not our immediate problem
let me just follow up with that because
I think as I discussed before we had
great I just want to thank all the
epidemiologists and scientists out there
who worked with us over the last four
weeks on models they really many came
forward and really supported us right
now we're in talks with the whole series
of universities we have the most
brilliant scientists in the world and
our universities in state after state
some of them public health universities
some of them basic science all of them
have received NIH grants for HIV or
other development of assays in the past
I've talked to a lot of them over the
last few days to really ask them to
develop these simple iliza tests that
could be used rapidly in their health
care centers because immediately with a
test it's easy to do we've all developed
eliza's so in a day or two after
development they could screen their
entire Hospital I think that would be
very reassuring to the health care
workers who have been on the frontline
we worry about them every day and so I
really called on every University in
every state to develop eliza's you can
buy the antigens and the controls online
and really work to test entire
healthcare communities in your States
and support them that way at the same
time we worked in sub-saharan Africa and
what we call dried blood spots so we're
looking at could you use that in a
community while we work on the
point-of-care test where you just dot
blood on to this paper and then that can
go into the lab and be analyzed that
would allow us to look in nursing homes
and other get long-term care facilities
immediately and then finally we've
reached out to the developers of the
rapid tests the ones who developed it
for malaria the ones that develop them
for HIV it's exactly the same concept
and process to ask them to rapidly
develop these tests because I think we
owe it to the frontline healthcare
providers not only to provide them RNA
tests but many of them have been on the
front line now for for weeks may have
become exposed we now know there's
asymptomatic and I think really being
able to tell them the peace of mind that
would come from knowing you already were
infected you have the antibody you're
safe from reinfection 99.9 percent of
the time and so this I think would be
very reassuring to our frontline health
care workers and our universities can do
that by Friday so I'm putting that
challenge out to them to really work on
that and do that that's what we did in
the early days we had Eliza's up and
running within days of having the
antigen and so this is what's really
possible so we're not waiting we're
asking for help now importantly this
could happen soon even within this month
could happen soon within this month
if the universities help us absolutely
[Music]
religious events for example large
religious groups can meet together and
that doesn't really great who can
religious groups like Jared examine me
but he did speak to me this morning we
talked about it please only concern does
that go against your model because
that's not fully I don't have to look at
what he did health care workers on the
front lines following up with dr. burns
as well hazard pay you have said you
have wanted that for the health care
workers on the
frontlines I know secretary minutiae Nez
mentioned something about that possibly
in the North level the stimulus I like
you but can you make it happen now do we
have to wait for a fourth slow I think
it's something we're discussing in terms
of bonus or bonus pay it doesn't have to
be called hazard pay it because hey look
I watched those people go into hospitals
that I know I talked about one of them
right but I watch them walk into those
hospitals and they walk in men women
young middle aged not so many older ones
and I walk i watch them they're almost
like and I think I take the word almost
after they're like warriors they're
going in people are cheering whether
there's a building across the street the
people are screaming that laughing there
they're like heroes
the Empire State no no I tell you I
think it's incredible
they're like they're like warriors
they're like soldiers and whether
they're gonna be doing something for
them but so whether it's bonus because
you know we're hopefully gonna be over
this relatively quickly like a month for
a period of time but hopefully we're
gonna be over this you have a lot of
questions so look at you there's you
know this young man I've never met her
before there are a lot of people who are
worried about getting sick and do they
end up in a hospital people who are
uninsured and will they be crushed by
medical bills you were considering last
month last month already in March
reopening the healthcare.gov exchanges
there has been a determination not to do
that could you tell us what the
rationale was behind that guy and and
what what you have is an alternative
okay they took that up under the task
force and make maybe Mike Mike come up
here in trash okay mr. president and
what I can tell you is that the
president has made a priority from the
outset of our task force work make sure
every American knows that they can have
a corona virus
and they don't have to worry about the
cost and we were very private a
coronavirus because of the president's
engagement with the leading health
insurance companies in the country that
now so far two of the top health
insurance companies in America have
announced that they're not only willing
to waive co-pays on testing and now
testing is fully covered because of the
bill the president signed for every
American but also their these two
insurance companies have waived co-pays
on all coronavirus treatment and I can
assure you that as Congress and the
president and the administration begin
to discuss the next piece of legislation
we're gonna make sure that Americans
have those costs compensated and covered
our priority right now is is is ensuring
that every American takes the 30 days to
slow the spread to heart the best thing
we can do for one another for our
family's health for the most vulnerable
among us is practice those mitigation
strategies that the president outlined
yesterday for the next 30 days we're
dealing with testing to make sure that
every American can have the test that
needs one we're dealing we're dealing
with supplies and we're making great
progress in building personal protective
equipment and ensuring that ventilators
are available particularly for the
communities most impacted but the
American people can be confident that as
we move into this we're gonna make sure
that our health care workers are
properly conferencing notice it's not an
answer the question was why didn't you
reopen the healthcare.gov exchanges
there were that the financial burden on
those who end up contracting the
coronavirus and dealing with its most
serious symptoms also can be can can
deal with those issues and deal with
those costs
understood mr. vice president but there
will be people who don't ever sir
who get sick before any of these
mitigation efforts are put into place
and without opening the health care
exchanges where can they find insurance
people who aren't insured by these
companies that are covering the cost of
the copay where can people go now to get
health insurance if they get sick before
they get well all across America we have
Medicaid four of your blue Americans and
at the president's direction the Center
for Medicaid Medicare Services has given
unprecedented waivers for states to
expand coverage for coronavirus testing
and treatment we've also extended
waivers for Medicare Administration to
make sure that people have access to
that coverage we can continue to bring
opportunities to the president the
traditional systems of Medicaid in
particular for the uninsured in America
and to cover middle class well I think
what we're seeing health insurance
companies do today job dangerous
question because if the answer is yes it
means Medicare for all is viable the
president's approach for you who already
have insurance well one of the things
that's that has animated and
characterized the president's approach
is the way he's engaged American
businesses to step up and do their part
and as the president said many gaslight
we're we're inspired by the spirit of
American businesses I was at a
distribution center for Walmart today
question was people without insurance
answer is distribution center for
Walmart's of people these workers are
coming to work the truck drivers are
coming to work farmers are working in
the field our history stores made a
commitment of the president a month ago
that no grocery store in America would
close down the food supply is strong
we're getting food on the table of every
American but it's because the president
went to these leaders and said we need
you to step up and do your part we we
engaged health insurance executives
early on in this process to wave to
waive co-pays on coronavirus testing and
and because of the engagement and
frankly because of that that patriotic
and compassionate spirit that's being
reflected we've already seen two of the
largest insurance companies in the
country announced that they're gonna
providing full coverage free of charge
for coronavirus treatment this guy
wouldn't answer if he had a gun to his
head as the president does to that we'll
see more of that for people that have
insurance will continue to provide
flexibility for Medicaid for people that
don't have insurance and we'll make sure
that Medicare has a flexibility to meet
this moment for seniors when we remember
that seniors with underlying health
conditions are the are the most
vulnerable to serious outcomes from the
coronavirus but we'll get through this
using the full weight of the federal
government and the full strength of the
Trump called out pence for not answering
the question I was a dinner to ask your
questions but this is a huge worry yeah
for people in this country who were in
that doughnut hole well you don't have
they don't have commercial insurance
they don't qualify for Medicare what do
you think we're looking at the entire
2000 election talking about the doughnut
hole and it's still there yeah we are
I haven't been up there yet you know
other people have been talking about it
and they haven't spoken this was 20
years ago when you're talking about but
they're talking about if they're talking
about it I know but they're talking
about it in the 2020 or like wow and
nobody's gotten to it no but I think
Pence's rip [ __ ] with Trump for calling
them out like that I really do we're
gonna get through it I don't I don't
think the other group will get to it
they haven't even spoken about it and
it's a big group of people
there's
are you committing that's okay I can't
commit I have to get approval from it I
have a thing called Congress but it's
something we're gonna look at and we
have been looking at it you mentioned in
this congressional bill the next the
sort of phase for you would like to see
something if there is a phase four but
we're certainly looking at certain
things we want to help restaurants
entertainment we want to help because
it's jobs not that restaurants it's jobs
tremendous amounts of jobs so we're
looking at that we're looking at
infrastructure and we think of it we
will have spent eight trillion dollars
and you know way back we're way pulled
back but we will have spent eight
trillion dollars in the middle east and
yet our roads are in bad shape our
bridges look at mansis furious smart and
we're gonna be the talk of the world
again soon but we want to trillion we
will have spent in the middle east and
all we got out of it was death and cost
but all we got out of it was death
millions of people you have to look at
the other side too millions and millions
of people killed our great soldiers what
thousands killed so many wounded hurt
and yet when we want to go and fix the
road someplace we want to do what we
want to do in our country no it's time
that we spend money on our country
that's what we're gonna do it's time
that we start spending on our roads and
our bridges and our schools and all of
the things that we're supposed to be
spending on and people are finally
getting used to it and you could look at
all of what we've done in the middle
east
way back in so many different places way
back in other countries too by the way
and I've gone to other countries that
are very rich I said I'm sorry you're
gonna have to reimburse us for our cost
they don't even want to know what I'm
talking about it takes them 20 minutes
to figure it out because nobody's ever
asked them to do that and they're doing
it they're doing it and they have no
choice they have to do it these are lies
so it's time that we start spending on
the USA okay place this person this is a
question for the
on March 9 you said 1 million tests had
been delivered and another 4 million
would be delivered by the end of the
week good question I clearly had not
happened what happened with those
rejections would well I think the test
kits were delivered across HHS but the
difference is between receiving a test
and the ability to rapidly produce a
result of that test and frankly because
of the public-private partnership that
the president initiated now more than a
month ago
right with our massive commercial
laboratories across the country
our team was reported today that we're
now doing more than a hundred thousand
tests a day more than 1.2 million tests
have been performed notice these numbers
are far short of the projections they've
been feeding us for three weeks states
have been so successful that the
community based and drive-through
testing that we're working to transition
over completely all of the federal work
on Drive through testing and and have
the states completely managed that
process was a million tests were
delivered by the end of that week HHS
was very busy from early in the year uh
delivering test kits around the country
but the difference was as the president
said many times we had an antiquated
system there the state laboratory or CDC
only had the capacity to process forty
to sixty tests a day now with the
commercial labs literally those labs are
processing tens of thousands of tests
every day and so while we're continuing
to distribute test kits around the
country now because of the partnership
with with companies like Roche and and
quest and
LabCorp the American people are seeing
the results of those tests more rapidly
than at any point in the past and Nexus
will continue to expand but the exciting
news this weekend excited about Abbott
Laboratories having a 15 minute test
approved is going to put us in a
position we believe down the road to get
to where dr. Fauci and dr. Burks want us
to be for many of the states that don't
yet have significant outbreak there's
some 19 states where we don't have
significant outbreak but we want to be
doing the kind of surveillance testing
in those states that will allow us early
on to identify people with the
coronavirus do what the experts call
contact tracing and ensure that in that
state we don't have we don't have an
outbreak of the corona virus so in many
countries all over the world want to
know whether or not they could use
especially our new test that we that was
just developed by Abbott which is almost
instantaneous which is going to be great
and remember this we inherited this we
inherited antiquated baya tests we
inherited beds have sisa harmful tests
and it was broken it was all broken and
we fixed it and we're doing millions of
tests sometimes we send out a test and
it's not used in many cases it wasn't
used but we worked with the states and
the testing has been pretty amazing
especially considering the fact that we
inherited a very broken system yet but
something you said
are you considering a temporary ban on
all domestic flights I am looking at hot
spots I am looking where flights are
going into hot spots some of those some
of those flights I didn't like from the
beginning but closing up every single
flight on every single airline that's a
very very very rough decision but we are
thinking about hot spots where you go
from spot to spot both hot and will let
you know fairly soon about rail a
similar thing we have trains going back
and forth and people don't think of
trains but we do a lot of transportation
business it's a very big decision to do
that and we're pretty late in the
process from the standpoint that this is
starting you're going to start seeing I
think over the next couple of weeks
you're going to start to see us hit a
tough and start coming down so we'll
make those decisions those are very very
those are very very big decisions from
the standpoint of of the future of our
country in a way in the future of our
country we have to get our country back
we have to start moving again we have to
start working again now they're doing
tests on Airlines very strong tests for
getting on getting off strong tests on
trains getting on getting off but when
you start closing up entire
transportation systems and then opening
them up that's a very tough thing to do
there continues to be a lot of public
confusion about the use
masks what is the way we use I love the
sterilization of the masks she's not
asking about that Ohio company you can
start asking about just everybody using
a mask in public God and you can
sterilize that mask for up to 20 times
not the question that only 20 times
we're throwing them out and they're very
expensive masks they're throwing them
out and I kept saying one of the first
questions I asked to doctor foul she I
said why aren't they sterilized or
cleaning the masks because I didn't you
know was it my thing exactly when we
first heard about this questions about
the public didn't even let her and now
we have a company and I guess the number
of companies one on Ohio a great one
that makes equipment where you can
sterilize a mask up to 20 times which is
fantastic okay what about the public
should we be wearing that right I don't
believe look there's the big things a
lot of people don't like it some people
don't like it because you're taking it
away from the medical professionals some
people don't like it for other reasons I
don't see where it hurts and it doesn't
have to be a mask it can be a scarf
scarf is highly recommended by the
professionals I don't see where it hurts
I think if frankly if people wanted to
do it we don't want to do anything
that's gonna take masks you're talking
about a tremendous amount of masks when
you do that we don't want to take them
away from our medical professionals but
I certainly don't see it hurting but
what I do see people doing now is using
scarfs and I think in a certain scarf
ending on the fabric I think at a
certain way of scarf is better it's
actually better it's not I'm going to
ask you about social distancing and how
it applies to religious organizations
yeah some churches as you know have
continued to hold service
even though you have advised people that
they need to practice social distancing
there was a pastor of a mega church in
Florida a little weekend who held
services that were that were attended by
several hundred people so my question to
you is should pastors be holding
services in the middle of this pandemic
and even if they do should Americans be
going well my biggest disappointment is
that churches can't meet in a time of
need rice is really a great time for
churches to be together for people to
get together on a four-day or whenever
any times like that and yet if you do
that if you do it close you're really
giving this invisible enemy a very big
advantage yeah so it's it's the biggest
I think the single biggest
disappointment is you can't one of the
reasons but it's mostly just to pick a
date as you know I called it
aspirational an aspirational date would
be Easter and I will tell you it's a
it's very very disappointing but again
you get too close and if somebody's sick
you're gonna probably catch it so you
have to be very careful Joe Biden's
campaign came out the statement today
with Biden Biden would be did he read
the statement or get some PR person as
far as I know the campaign was wide
awake sir any Sunday's that doesn't
meant that Joe Biden would be open to
having a phone call with you to talk
about the coronavirus I sure would you
take his call we talked about this
because I'd like I'd be in touch he
should be here together
I always happen to be a nice guy I don't
know him very well frankly there you go
I think he's is probably a nice guy no
get on the phone aleut ly take his cool
Wow we could tell ministration and
leaving you with empty shelves and no
plans well there's no I'm gonna shoot
think I stay together we didn't do that
that turned out to be a false stories
now you're starting to go
what are you working for CNN
pointing out what they have said what
you have to do it with us the Fox isn't
so easy either don't kid yourself
resident look John let me tell you
something you see you know that's a
false story what you just said is a
false story this doctor knows it better
than anybody know but you shouldn't be
repeating a story that you know is false
all right who's go ahead what's that
particular moment economy under which
conditions would you consider suspending
save US sanctions look we have to talk
to them I think we could work out a deal
with a run very quickly all they have to
do is call I just think that you know
they're proud people and the leadership
is proud that proud like all of us we're
proud you people are proud they're
having a hard time picking up the phone
or they're having a hard time setting up
the meeting right but they could fix
their country pretty easily and we don't
want hostility but if they are hostile
to us they're going to regret it like
they've never regretted anything before
as per today's statement but all they
have to do is call or have somebody call
you know there are channels where we can
deal very easily right again I think
that John curry did a tremendous
disservice I think he violated the Logan
Act a hundred percent that's what I
think and I think it made it tough for
them because they were dealing with him
for years it was a terrible deal all of
that money 150 billion dollars plus cash
plus cash plane loads of cash for a deal
that was no good and was short-term
essentially it was a short-term deal who
makes a deal for that kind of money and
1.8 billion dollars in cash I don't even
know what that would look like that
would be this rule would have to be
filled up five times with hundred-dollar
bills okay
who makes it deal like this and then on
top of it the deals no good alright how
about one or two more
president Seattle Police have reported a
surge in calls about domestic violence a
number of groups of grace because our
Mexican workers domestic number of
concerns exit along papilla people are
stocking the more domestic violence
cases there are going to be do you share
those concerns and what is being done
with natures and how the cost of of not
getting our country working I mean
people are now some people are getting
along great I've also had the up is the
exact opposite question people families
are coming together right they're
actually coming together they haven't
talked for a long time and now all of a
sudden they're talking again they're
loving each other so I've heard that too
but I also have heard domestic violence
much trumps reportedly started talking
to Tiffany again and drug use because of
in this case they'd lose their jobs they
had a great job that a great life they
have a great family all of a sudden her
husband's told that he doesn't have a
job anymore and he's got no money the
husband's told and that brings drugs
into it that brings suicide into it it's
a terrible thing we have to get our
country going again we did the right
thing we had no choice we did the right
thing other countries tried to use the
heard or the herd mentality it's just
you know something that doesn't work if
you look at I mean just to say I heard
Sweden gave it a shot and they would
they would say so things that were
really frightening and they went
immediately to shutting down the country
they went kablooey we did the right
thing and we did it early we did it
early and we stopped other people from
coming into our country early but but no
that's a cost that's a I've been talking
about that people say what are you
talking about but you will have you'll
have that you'll have domestic violence
you have violence you'll have suicide
you'll have drug addiction a lot of
people are going to be lost we want to
get this open as soon as we can I mean
I'll be the happiest person so will you
everyone in this room happy when we get
the word that this is the time and we
have our common sense and they'll give
me a decision or they'll be making
certain statements enough I think
know how to interpret those statements
very well I'll be with Mike I'll be with
the task force I'll be with a lot of
very talented people including the two
people on stage with us but I look
forward that'll be a great day that'll
be a great day all right how about one
more please
what is the current contingency planning
next detention centers were cases of
public 19 are already popping up some
people have been release is there a
contingency plan and would you release
it'll most vulnerable people like
children and the elder well ice looks at
on a case-by-case basis even well before
kovat on looking at certain detention
facilities and determine on a
case-by-case basis if they need do need
to release individuals and when we do
that we awfully put them on alternatives
to detention as well in the case of
kovat we're looking at vulnerable
populations and again ice is doing that
in conjunction with CDC and other
medical professionals in some cases we
do need to do that for the health and
safety and the well-being of those
detainees but again that's a
case-by-case basis we're not gonna make
any blanket statement that we're going
to release individuals of whole groups
at a time so it's really important and
I've said it through twice now it's a
really a case-by-case basis determining
the health of that particular population
or detainee the the facility they're in
different facilities have different
capabilities whether it's a nice own to
facility or it's a contractor own
facility and so we're certainly doing
that we're doing that today
we've done been doing that for the past
several weeks absolutely we have
continued to build miles of the wall
every day we're up to over 150 I believe
we're continuing to build new new miles
of wall and a lot of folks asked about
replacement wall or new miles and it's a
new capability on our southwest border
that we haven't had before so whether
you talk to the agents the Border Patrol
agents they like that capability like
they like that impedance and denial that
it provides them and it provides the
ability for those agents to focus
elsewhere on parts of the border that
are very difficult to patrol so we can
use our resources in a different way and
so we see a lot of benefits from the
border wall system and again that
includes not only the physical
infrastructure but the cameras the roads
the Lighting's the fiber-optic cables
and we're looking forward and we're
still well on our track well
our mark to meet 400 450 miles by the
end of the calendar year there's been
concern among farmers about being able
to get enough migrant labor to keep the
food supply moving as we go into the
harvest season what are you doing to
address that well at the direction of
the vice-president and the task force we
are looking at a number of different
options with the h-2a workers that you
mentioned on how do we either extend the
validity of their visa or looking at a
couple of different options nothing to
announce here today but again out the
direction of the president the vice
president we're looking at a very
variety of different options that I
think we will have soon and it'll be
very beneficial because we want the
farmers they've had this for years we
want the farmers to be able to get the
people that have been working those
farms for years so we're not gonna have
farms so they're gonna come in and
they're gonna be given a certain pass
and we're gonna check them very very
closely especially over the next month
because remember after a month or so I
think once this passes we're not gonna
have to be hopefully we're too much
about the virus but we want them to come
in we're not closing the border so that
we can't get any of those people to come
in they've been there for years and
years and I've given the commitment to
the farmers they're gonna continue to
come well we're not gonna have any
farmers okay
waving these okay who else in less than
24 hours sir to ship fool arrived at
Port Everglades with people of who are
looking at the two ships yeah we have a
we have Canada notified a lot of
Canadians a lot of British on the ship
and they're coming to take the people
that are on the ship back to their
homeland home Canada is coming a UK is
coming and we have a lot of and we have
Americans we have some people that are
quite sick and we're taking care of that
I'm speaking with the governor about
that a lot and it's a tough situation
it's a tough situation you know like you
can understand you have people that are
sick on those ships and states don't
want to take they have enough problems
right now they don't want to take them
but we have to from a humane standpoint
we don't have a choice it's like I don't
want to do that but we have to people
are dying
we're gonna do something we're gonna do
something at a minimum we're sending
medical teams on board the ships we're
taking the Canadians off and giving them
to Canadian authorities they're going to
bring them back home separate connect
same thing with the UK but we have to
help the people there if they're in big
trouble no matter where no matter where
they're from happen to be Americans
largely Americans but whether they were
or not I mean they're dying so we have
to do something and and the governor
knows that - were being sent on well
we're sending a lot of them home you
know we're sending a lot of our home to
their countries but we'll be doing
something and we'll be announcing it
you'll see what we're doing but we're
also putting medical staff onto the
ships so that we can we have to take
care of the people
but the risk of you getting chewed out
again mr. president there is a the IRS
is requiring people who don't normally
file income tax to file a simple income
tax return in order to get their $1200
check is that the way it's going to be
yours there's something you can do I had
heard that now I don't know do you know
that answer we could get back yeah it's
being it's a process that they're
working on we'll get back to you as soon
as we find out all right one more please
he's great
he's a great guy and he's from Brazil
welcome this morning just a very
complimentary call he's working very
hard he's got a problem with the virus
got a big problem and he's we talked
about it today at length we had a call
this morning and Brazil is shut down as
you know they weren't going to shut it
down but they had to so Brazil has shut
down the world is shut down right
nobody's ever seen anything like this
the entire world is shut down you go
from having the most powerful economy in
the world and from other countries that
are doing well to being everything is
shut down it's very sad but we're gonna
get it going and we're gonna be stronger
than ever I really believe that we're
gonna be stronger we're gonna have a big
bounce a very big bounce when this is
gone dead cat bounce and I just want to
thank the American people I want to
thank these great professionals and I
want to thank the media because really
for the most part the media has been
very fair thank you very much everybody
so there it is the daily propaganda with
two minutes of dr. fowey and 15 seconds
of dr. deborah birx we did learn some
things although they are mostly not
particularly good thanks to everybody
who's been joining me I'll hang around
for a little bit just while we get a
look at kind of Copeland's face here and
answer some questions I am being
notified that we have scaled resources
at join pakman.com the website crashed
the entire thing collapsed like a house
of cards because so many people try to
get memberships I'm told the website is
running very very strongly right now
we've looked at it beautifully we've
some extraordinarily beautiful HTML and
caching and/or cash as Trump likes to
say and this would be a great
opportunity to to grab those memberships
for sure thanks to Chris Kiefel who says
thanks Danny thanks Danny just moved
back to Minnesota
okay Oh Danny says I see Minnesota
opened 30-day special period for EM
ensure Jane womanpower says thanks for
helping us deal with the nausea and
insanity of Trump David thanks to Bryan
Holaday for saying Trump just made his
own VP look like an idiot yeah it was
rich but pence did not seem pleased when
Trump said wow he just he just he just
didn't answer the question five minutes
I see people saying we've never seen
memberships like these before yeah we
never have seen 389 memberships
cancelled in one month before which we
saw in March and I get why it's
happening it's because of the virus but
fortunately we've got some folks signing
up let me say thank you to Jen
concepción who is new member number 16
today Barbara Ellis is number 17
Amy Guerra is number 18 Stephen Ron is
number 19 Paul Burbridge is new member
number 20
Tammy Vick is new member number 21 don't
want to forget of course about Kathleen
Cushing who's new member number 22 today
M / I don't know if that's some kind of
abbreviation is new member number oh
sorry not - 23 23 also thanks to Colin
Webb whose new member number 24 today
Daniel Legrand is new member number 25
oh and I can't forget about Matthew
Ferren Bock Matthew Ferran Bock is a new
member number 26 lends the ecers is new
member number 27 and I also want to say
thanks - did I miss somebody there
Nick monitor hello Nick monitor is new
member number 28 Alecia Babineaux is
number
twenty-nine Michael Chacho I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly geez number
30
Kimberly Roberts Kruger is number 31
today Brian Somerville love Somerville
is number 32
also thanks to ODS Ramsey who is new
member number 33 Clinton Dean is number
34 someone who goes by the name triple F
triple are not sure if that's a legal
name is new member number 35 today also
thanks to Tim Thomas Tim Thomas is new
member number 36 and Jake
Sammy a is new member number 37 I hope I
got to everybody there oh also the great
Donna Chen is new member number 38 very
much appreciate that we will be back
tomorrow I hope with a better
functioning website than we had today
see everybody tomorrow for the regular
show and then probably back here at 5:00
p.m. pending Donald Trump's briefing
scheduled